welcome back to chess.com i'm not gm
speechless championship grand master
robert hess alongside me today grand
master of mont hamilton
amman you've had quite a busy schedule
lately how you feeling today
what's up robert and uh hello to twitch
chad good to be back good to be back
i have been commentating a lot but you
know i
i'd like to think that this is just you
know twitch rivals maybe it was just
practice for this
i am not a gm tournament robert yeah i
like to say no rest for the fantastic
commentators you are great so no rest
for you and let's remind everybody
of what we're here for today because
it's been a while this is the i'm not a
gm speed chess championship the format
is the following as you see in front of
you we have
a bracket single elimination knockout 75
minutes of five minute plus one second
increment blitz followed by 45 minutes
of the three plus one and finally 25
minutes of everyone's favorite ebola
chess
only the winner survives and advances we
will have the
one of the two finalists after today's
match and the prize money among it's
getting bigger
and the participants should be quite
happy to take home 450
by themselves plus the 450 split by win
percentage and of course
the chance at the championship yeah
that's that's awesome i
you know we were both a part of
yesterday the
twitch rivals event where we saw uh so
many people
taking home cash for their participation
and i'd like to see those rewarding
formats where
players are taking home cash regardless
of uh where they place
absolutely and we're going to remind
everybody of what we're here for today
it
is international master molina an
international master at lars oscar hogg
and as you see in the bracket there are
only four people remaining we are on the
right side of the screen here
roberto lars on the left side we have
greg shahadi
taking on levy rosman and i guess before
we
dive into today's match amman what do
you make of the other one between
greg and levy i'm sure so many people
are excited for greg shahadi and
gotham chess yeah i mean at this point
um the i am not a gm tournament has
progressed
to the semi-final stage so we are so
close to
crowning that uh winner and greg shahadi
uh speaking of potential winners number
one seed going into the entire event
he's obviously a front-runner um i think
there is a lot of
fans of both sides here but you have the
number one seed in greg shahadi and then
you have
you know fan favorite levy rosman who i
think you'll maybe echo this but every
match we've commented of his so far has
been
extremely exciting so i can't wait for
this this is going to be
really really tough to call i think greg
has to be the favorite going in but
i think what we've seen from levy is
that he can win any match
especially in the bullet segment that's
right he's been gaining rating recently
he's been posting about that crossing
to 2800 blitz of course and so
he is in good form but that's enough of
that matchup let's talk about today we
have roberto
we have lars oscar hogg they are about
to begin
and i'm not sure who the favorite is i
know that lars has been dominant in the
bullet portion
he has really just been cruising by his
opponents there
but he struggled out of the gates in the
blitz portion his openings have left him
in a bit of trouble so whose style do
you think will be better
between these two players well i think
that
uh and what we do know about these
players as the
first game is uh underway here what we
do know about these players is uh i
think we're gonna see a big style
mismatch which is why i'm so excited for
the match today
because uh roberto very very solid you
know
uh if you if you give the guy a trade
he'll take five of them
so uh he'll be looking to go for those
end games but more positional style
and we've seen a very loose play from
lars which is why i think
uh he's been doing so well in bullet i
think you're rewarded for being a little
bit more loose in your style
when it comes to bullet chests where you
can't calculate everything else so
efficiently but
in the blitz portion look for roberto to
try to press the advantages i would say
because i think that they're gonna see a
few openings that don't necessarily go
um in the way of lars oscar i agree with
that and we already see
that roberto takes the calmer approach
on move five he went
e3 rather than playing the more
adventurous tactical sequences with e4
so
roberto calmly enters this position here
where white has a bit more space thanks
to that pawn on d4
but black has no weaknesses that can be
targeted so i would say
that these styles of position are more
up roberto's alley
hence his opening choice in game one
yeah and that
uh column approach with e3 is gonna mean
uh you know you're not gonna see these
types of positions where
uh i guess we might see c5 it could
immediately get very symmetrical
after something like c5 d capture c5 and
we get a position like that and uh just
looking at the position already i know
that lars has got to be happy with
his opening because um it's actually one
of the one of the more solid approaches
we've seen from him
at the same time it seems like it's the
exactly what roberto wants
starting off here that's true and i
think now if he's gonna
start getting active i move like knight
e5 comes to mind you typically want to
place a knight in the square
try to replace it with a pawn but i do
like bishop e1 first because you want
the opening of the d-file
not just a pawn on e5 so i like bishop
e1 it's very calm
it challenges lars to figure out do i
take on d4 no keeping the tension with
d8
and d5 is an additional possibility for
white i'm just not sure how that plays
out
agree yeah d5 is the first thing that i
think of here
with bishop takes c3 being met by
potentially just d6
and in the meantime after d5 if you
exchange everything on that square
sometimes those end games they might
look like nothing
robert but uh those equal end game
positions with that
slight imbalance of pawns four versus
three for white on the king side
three versus two for black on the queen
side those can sometimes
materialize into serious advantages at
this high level
yeah you can be lulled into a sense of
comfort oh it's a fine position
nothing major happening but those end
games as you're saying they can be quite
difficult to
hold and right now look at lars he's
trying to figure out what to do he is
down
40 seconds on the clock and still not
making a move yet
because he's trying to figure out do i
take on d4 do i play
h6 just to make luft for my king what
move would you play here mom
well um yeah obviously i play
c takes d4 robert um but yeah see
cd4 is always on the cards for black
that that pawn tension there
i was wondering mostly how roberta was
going to recapture if i
i had to make a prediction i would have
actually said that he would take back
with a piece
rather than a pawn just stylistically
but he's taken back with the pawn
he's looking at these d5 options still
and
he does have that 95 move that you
mentioned so long ago so i think this
game
is sort of revolving around the fact
that the knight on f6 cannot
jump into d5 so easily um because white
can
immediately white can win a piece but um
or not quite win a piece but
uh at least force that e pawn to capture
back
and that knight on d7 can't really get
to b6 to d5 which is a really common
maneuver so
i think the issue in this game is might
be surprising but the knight on d7
robert
doesn't have a lot of places to go and
after 95
white's going to be tempting him to
trade that's true and the
997 dominated by pawn three squares away
that d4 pawn taking away four jumps
and also i would say that pawn on a6 a
big problem for black
notice how lars went rook f to d and
then rook d
to e8 and he still can't move his rook
on a8 because it's attached to that pawn
on a6 where the queen and bishop are
lined up
on that side of the board so this is a
tricky position for lars to deal with
and look at the clock i mean so much
more time for white here
bishop f4 is the move that i played
there he goes that bishop went from e1
doing not so much to f4 where maybe it's
not threatening anything just yet but
it's a strong piece
and now we're going to see trade you
said give him one he'll take five
i think uh let's uh let's get trades for
three
yeah i'll get a get a full uh full-size
offering of trades with bishop h2 well
i'm almost proud i'm almost
proud watching here robert well he said
if we're gonna trade it's gonna be a my
turn to take on c3 help my pawn out but
that knight on d7
ahmad you mentioned it it gets out but
in comes knight to e5
i do feel like we're still in roberto's
wheelhouse but it's getting a bit
sharper now that the knight on d7 has
ventured over to f6
yeah i definitely think that um taking
on d5
was a sort of a one-time opportunity a
limited time offer because
the pawn would have to recapture and
after knight uh
to f6 all of a sudden the pieces can
handle
the recapturing rook a to c8 robert goes
back to what you were mentioning about
the a6 bond i mean
why is uh is that pawn safe here can he
get away with rook a to c8
i don't think so knight takes d5
followed by bishop takes a6 is what i'm
going for without much of hesitation
uh there it goes step one complete and
no matter how you take on d5
the a6 pawn goes down so it's one of
these positions amman where you start
feeling all right i'm doing better as
black my first knight gets to d5
my superfluous knight gets to f6 and now
one trade down goes a6 and you're just
down a pump
perhaps there's some kind of queen g5 at
some timely moment
hitting g2 hitting c1 i'm not quite sure
it works out
but i would be looking for that kind of
tactical sequence
yeah a hundred percent if if bishop
takes a6 i'm already wondering about
rook takes c1 followed by queen g5
as an idea hitting the rook on c1 and
eyeballing that g2 square
um the bishop is still going to be on b7
so
there's still some firepower lined up
there and it's also going to be stuff
like
you know knight f4 knight c3 discovered
attacks
um if white's not careful so that's what
uh roberto
is thinking about here and and we
mentioned the style clash at the
beginning of this matchup
i think that those types of positions
are where lars
really really thrives where it gets
messy and tactical
and he does have that sharp tactical
vision
and you know that's for sure the case
based on the time situation where now
we're about even on the clock
bishop takes a6 was played roberto puts
on his calculation cap and decides to go
for it but queen g5 right now
is played by lars he doesn't need to be
asked twice where does this rook go to
amman
yeah where does the rook go to is a
great question because
um knight f4
sort of looks like a i guess there's
maybe queen g4 or something
in in the position like that but uh
it it looks really suspicious here i i
don't really
know where this was like if you go rook
to d1
or basically a rook to any normal square
i get the feeling that black should be
fairly happy with uh
some of the tricks in the position maybe
even just bishop to a8 um next move
robert just
keep that guy and say all right uh i'm
gonna threaten some stuff next turn it's
up to you
i think you have to avoid the knights
jump because we keep looking at knight
f4 and that's where my mind was i was
tunneling but after rook d1 maybe
there's knight
c3 because now we hit the queen and the
rook in the event of queen g4
so maybe you have to play move like rook
a1 just hide your rook
all the way away just to avoid some kind
of knight jump that would
hit that rook in addition to the g2
square with checkmate
that's crazy rook a1 being required here
is
that's a tough uh pill to swallow yeah
because other moves like rook
he goes rook c2 maybe that's also
sufficient i thought there would be a
knight jump because but then i can't
take the own bishop on
b4 but you need to stay out of the
bishop's path out of the
knights path all of these pieces for
black doing well
but your ideas is coming to fruition
here after knight f4
which looks like a mating idea queen
comes to g4 to stop the checkmate and
yes that bishop
a6 will lose the defender but then
knight and f4 will lose its defender as
well so we're actually seeing a very
weird series of trades and the tactics
are flying
yeah and i think that position after
knight f4 queen g4 is gonna liquidate
favorably for um for roberto and he's
going to be on the open file as well
which is important
if that rook was on a1 like you
mentioned
maybe that black can go for that line
and just go rook c8 at the end and start
invading so
it is something to pay attention to that
keeping the queens on the board here is
something you want to do is is bishop a8
uh crazy because with 48 seconds to 50
seconds
if my knight f4 stuff is not working
here i'm not too sure what to do i might
just play bishop a8 instinctively
it's one of these positions where i feel
like you have to trust your intuition
and play
metaphor but he's thinking too long at
this point because uh bishop a8
then queen g4 anyway and it feels like
the queens are
coming off or you're backtracking and
you no longer have an attack
but lars now is down on the clock
roberto probably feeling
much happier about the state of his
position and 94 eventually was played
but what's the follow-up
yeah you can take this bishop right away
or you can decide to
trade the queens rook c2 is actually
really nice instead of
rook a1 it prevents like queen d2 in a
lot of lines
so it means the queens definitely get
traded off bishop takes f4
and these are the trades that we're
seeing but this is why i was uh
pointing out robert it's so good that
the rook is on c2
on the open file and knight c6 isn't
that just a
big fork yeah that's game over that's
forking the rook and the bishop there's
not no way you can protect the bishops
you're going down a full piece
after movement resignation spot wow
did you see roberto there yeah he feels
so relieved
after a stressful game one and lars is
like
i mean he's he's shell-shocked from the
blender but
he doesn't look that faced all right
that's that's game one for you you know
just getting started here just getting
warmed up that's the key
just getting started and because roberto
is more
of a kind of a traitor a player who
wants to
say let's get pieces off the board not
have it be so complicated
he has to bring his gut with him today
he's not just going to
be in here all right easy games look at
this what is this position
on move seven right we have pawns going
up the board
there's already some kind of f takes e5
queen h4 check available
is that good i'm not positive but nor is
roberto
and i'm sure lars isn't either but we're
getting crazy positions
from the very start of the games yeah
this is uh
this is trademark lars you know the
position is going to get
um pretty spicy after a move like this
because
immediately i think you know everyone's
eyes should be drawn to the idea of
hey pawn takes pawn on e5 and no matter
how that is recaptured
black is already thinking about the move
queen h4 check just an immediate
uh you know attack when you see the move
g4 and f4
i mean we all know fools checkmate mr
hess
and i mean those two moves invite a
check like that i mean
what are we seeing here i think that
we're going to see maybe a g5 at some
point and we're going to lock that side
of the board up but
that bishop on g6 not looking that great
although the g5 perhaps it goes to h5
just to try to keep that side
close i don't think that black can get
away with this i really believe that g5
knight g3
h4 just start throwing our pieces up the
king side
and i'm not liking roberto's position
that much
yeah after after f5 like
g5 h4 with knight g3 coming looks uh
looks like a lot of fun i think there's
probably i was about to say a knight g3
like a more aggressive way to
do the same thing where uh you want
maybe pawn takes pawn and then you could
take back with the queen
you're coming with h4 h5 bishop d3
um this is going to be a fight for some
of the light squares on the king side
it's really all about this f5 square if
black
can you know continuously take back with
a piece and establish a piece on that
square
he's got a really solid position
meanwhile bishop d3
lars is not looking to to let that
happen i think you take on g4 though and
if you take on g6 maybe black plays
h takes g6 and gets a strong hold of
this f5 square with the pawns it doesn't
look pretty i acknowledge that
but you can't allow yourself in there we
see the start of it you can't allow
yourself
to just be pushed back move after move
and h takes g6 is a must here we go and
i think king f7 your king is
surprisingly safe there
because of the pawn on d5 right knight
can't get over to g5 but for now
i mean it makes sense let's try to
castle queen side that's probably
smarter not my games i'll put my king
out of seven and
don't deal with the consequences but
here he just brings his king to the
queen side and
how does white make progress despite the
pleasant looking position
well i um immediately think of something
like
i mean h4 just kind of locks everything
down if you really want to open things
up and
meanwhile undermine the f5 square
robert i think of h4 h5 to get rid of
the g
pawn in that case there's also you know
if you're ever not sure what to do in a
position like this
how about the move king v1 and king v8
those moves are your friends robert when
you
queenside castle and you don't know what
to do next
i think most people especially stronger
players will agree that
hey if you play king b1 or king b8
you're not doing something wrong
um was he there partner and i think
strategically white is in a better
position
because this knight on a6 is going to
have to resort to passive defense going
to c7
in the near future but then again the
knight nc7 is very helpful because the
pawn e6
is a target but i like this move h5
you're trying to
remove the defense of this f5 knight and
queen f7 i think is a nice response
because after h6 g6
rook takes g6 at least for the time
being
white isn't just quick enough to take on
f5 so i like
how both players are playing this and i
could see this turning in roberto's
favor i didn't like his position to
start with now all of a sudden
it seems like he's stabilized and that
rook h6 move in particular
felt clever yeah the the one
i guess fairly concrete line i'm looking
at is takes on g6
a rook g6 followed by queen h5
um and if somehow i can play knight
takes f5 successfully
and force upon the recapture not sure
about the end game i feel like white
should be slightly preferred
last night will eventually reach the e6
square so
it's barely double-edged i i would say i
don't don't think either side is
uh got anything to write home about just
yet that's the annoying thing right your
whole goal is to undermine the defense
f5 and then when you do it a knight
appears on e6 and you're like darn it
knights are the best blockading pieces
but i think you have to
take on g6 at some point you're sort of
running out of time you don't want to
allow black to double in the h file and
start causing some problems so
here we do see that trade and queen h5
now
that seems completely reasonable but
said he backs it up to f3 yeah
queen queen h5 looked uh looked very
normal i mean queen f3 is
absolutely nothing wrong with that move
but um queen h5 seemed to make sense to
me i guess it would be met by rook f8
all the same yeah there's no way to pile
up on the pinned
rook that would have been there so the
queen would have been defended anyway
so now there's this crazy amount of
tension along the f5 the f5 square and
the f4 pawn behind it
if white takes an f5 then in comes
black's queen to f5 where
look at that c2 pawn by the way i'm on a
timely knight b4
could spell some serious trouble for
white that's a great point
that's a great point we might see an
immediate rook h5
after queen takes f5 in order to
dissuade
exactly what you're talking about you
don't have time to get knight before in
you've got to move your queen back to f7
and then temporarily
white is the one who sort of has control
over that f5 square we might see rook h5
f5 knight f4 just some quick activation
ideas
that would be a thematic pawn sack but
if the rook h5 can play rook g5 and
offer you a trade
wow that's just cute
i think you have to because i don't want
to be pushed back queen f70 f5 looks
like a great pawn sack
he goes queen g4 all right not giving
white the opportunity to press forward
just yet
but i thought rookie five was a way to
trade some pieces and keep
some of the pressure on white's position
he was neither as passive as i was
suggesting or as flashy as you were
suggesting
just queen g4 nice and simple uh get
those trades in
and white's better here because that
knight on e2 covers f4
whereas the g7 pawn the e6 pawn those
are both weaknesses rook h7 being the
obvious next move
for white just putting pressure on the
pawn and i think that black
it's about time maybe knight c7 your
knight going up to b4 does all of
nothing
it'll get kicked right back to a6 so
knight c7 at least protects e6
one of your two potential
vulnerabilities yeah the other
move i would consider is just king over
um
king d7 seems ever more natural than
king
d8 but same idea that you may want to
bring that king to f7 at some point and
uh one thing to watch out for even
though it's tempting is
let's say this king gets to f7 and white
starts thinking about f5
sometimes takes takes and you know the
black king goes to e6 or if the rooks
get traded
black is the one that's going to have
the outside pass pawn so although white
is going to get a protected pass bond in
the middle
we've talked already about how it can be
blockaded uh
successfully and i i know he's got f5
available but
i'm just not sure that that's
necessarily the right right way to
proceed robert
yeah that's a good point because we've
been talking to f5 for so long that you
made just that you have to play it when
given the opportunity
and now i'm blacking by king g6 and say
you're not getting your f5 movement
uh-huh everyone's bringing the king
towards the middle
finally that knight does retreat uh to
c7 looking to
get involved somehow and it now i think
the move f5 is less and less
likely because the knight is ready to
jump into e6 and you give black
the outermost past pawn when you play f5
because
right now the g7 pawn is met by the f4
pawn but as soon as you play f5 and get
some trades then the g pawn actually
becomes a passer so
i'm with you i think that f5 is less and
less likely but i don't know how to
proceed otherwise me i would say b3 and
c4 but i'm like
then what the d5 square is so well
defended i don't actually know
how to break through here yeah i think
this is the type of position where you
just kind of play
c3 you kind of play a4 a few uh
a few moves for white that seem natural
i also wouldn't be surprised by maybe
the king even
rerouting further towards the king side
and uh basically the position is exactly
what it says it is
uh dead level and i think that lars is
the one who actually has to accept the
draw here because if he
gives up control of the h file he could
be in trouble so after king g7 the next
move will be rook h8 but rook h8 here
will be met by f5 because the rook on g1
pins the pawn on g6 to the king that's
why roberto shifts his king right back
to f7
perhaps he could you know move his work
i would not even think about it at this
point no reason to get tactical
you're holding steady with the black
pieces and the draws agreed
yeah and that's a sort of a
just feeling out just feeling out the uh
the competition here
draw early on both players get on the
scoreboard
you know you're you're probably happy as
lars just to get that half point up
there
and go to the next game that's not the
type of position that we've seen lars
score his points from in this tournament
so far
right and now we get to game three once
again the white pieces for roberto
he plays a very solid position right he
just
pushes pawns in the center developed
castled kingside gave his opponent an
isolated queen pond
but perhaps this is a position that
suits both of them
because strategically from a structural
point of view
white is happy to give black an isolated
pawn but lars is saying wait a second
maybe i'll get a
an attack on the h2 pawn you don't have
a knight on f3 so if i can line my
pieces up
against your king side there are some
attacking prospects i think
both players should be happy out of the
opening
yep i agree um this looks
like uh just right off the bat it sort
of feels like one of those isolated pawn
positions where
black should be a bit happier than than
usual um i always find that bishop on f3
to be a little bit awkward
moves like knight e5 putting pressure
immediately
on that bishop and knight takes e6
is sort of like a fake threat like i
never really am convinced by
knight takes e6 because black takes with
the f pawn and opens up the rook and
immediately is threading like moves like
e5 e4
so i'm not too sure if uh
roberto should be that happy with his
position he's already gotten rid of the
isolated pawn by capturing on c6
yeah something has gone wrong i don't
like the decision to take on c6 but
as you point out knight e5 was probably
a concern of his and that's why he took
there
but now that pawn on d5 is very well
defended and okay i'm taking with the f
pawn
but perhaps queen takes is the right
choice here but i would take with the f
pawn and not even think about it
because then you have a mobile pawn
center and here comes e5 you mentioned
that move
then perhaps e4 and what are these
bishops doing for white it feels like
you're
several moves behind in terms of
development mm-hmm
yep no definitely a more of a lars move
to play
f takes e6 like he's very interested in
the imbalances
um and it's not even for that reason
that you might play it because look at
that center i mean how
how do you say no to that there's no c
pawn that's going to be undermining uh
the center here
can't even push e the e pawn that easily
like e4
definitely a move i would consider but
tough to play if white can get e4
and black plays d4 those are the type of
light square imbalances that i think
roberto would be looking to create
but after b4 he's hinting at you know
queen b3
b5 trying to undermine this way i think
it could be a little bit slow here
robert
yeah you desperately try to seize
control the light squares for your
bishop but i like black's position we
both do
and one of the ideas that i do like
about this b4 move is
black could have considered pawn e4 and
bishop to e5
when your opponent has a bishop pair and
you can trade off one of them
and then have a knight against a bishop
you can dominate the other color complex
however
b4 does have this continued threat of
undermining the pawns
on d5 that pawn needs to be defended by
that pawn on c6 for the most part
the a7 pawn stuck in place potentially a
target with queen a4
at some moment so i'm not sure anymore
i'm sort of second guessing myself i
like black's position and all of a
sudden saying
this doesn't look so easy to make
progress despite this great pawn center
and this bishop on d6 yeah that's a
that's a good point the the move e4
opens up the bishop towards the king but
without the access to the g4 square for
black's knight
it's very hard to coordinate on that
square like you know you don't have uh
bishop b8
queen d6 so easily and if you do white
will happily just play g3
and uh and kill that idea so uh
i agree it sort of feels like one of
those positions that lars is maybe
getting the same feeling that you and i
are right now
if you look at the clock i mean he's
down more than a in a minute
getting close to a minute and a half
that uh he's thinking here because he's
trying to find
the right plan and speaking of the right
plan i don't think that c5 is the right
plan but it's what he's chosen because
he had to make a move
just couldn't find what he should do so
he went for this and
it's not bad i don't think either of us
believe that but after
this trade on d6 coming our way or maybe
i guess you have to trade d6 now because
it works in c4 and then just
moves like queen b3 omega 3 is bad
because rook b8 but
well it knows bishop takes d5 check
that's actually a really cool tactic
i blundered it there you go robert
oh my gosh well there are tactics
everywhere it seems but
that's been sweet yeah i i it was a
mistake that it happened but
i'm just going through some of these
positions and yeah
you know what robert you've convinced me
i you deserve a spot
on the analysis board thank you thank
you
you know rookbee it looks like it just
kicks the queen away but the queen on d6
can't take on d5 and protect the rook on
v8 so
beautiful oh gosh so
what what's this position though i'm on
because it does feel like black is way
more
active here and yet i see the eval bar
on screen saying
completely equal yeah i mean well
unfortunately your bishop d5
isn't working in every position so we
can't lean on that here
queen b4 looking for a queen trade and
queen d3
uh there's e4 to consider so lots and
lots of reasons
why you know you'd be tempted by the
trade i think that allowing the trade on
b3
is sort of comfortable because you take
with the b pawn and you can swing your
rook over to
a file so even something simple and
calm on the on the king side like g3 or
h3
just that a little escape square so your
rook can go to the a file afterwards
and do something aggressive like rick
takes a7 i think that would be the best
way forward and
roberto he knows how to play these end
games and it just seems like some pawns
will get traded off and neither side
will have enough remaining and the pawns
will be on the same side of the board
sure black has
two central pawns and then two king side
pawns and white only has one
pawn island but the knight is very good
on f6 defending his d5 pawn so there's
nothing
to worry about from black's perspective
and from white's perspective it's like
you can't attack anything
once the queen's come off so it seems
like it should just be an equal game
yeah and i like the move queen before uh
by lars it might not be
you know the move that gets the
brilliancy award or anything like that
but
i think that if you stayed in the
position with queens uh
on the board it was going to benefit
roberto the the longer the game went
on a simple move like rook d1 coming up
next would put a lot of pressure on the
d-pawn with the queen on d6 you'd be
threatening queen takes c4
so i just like the idea to trade off um
even though it might not be
uh you know the most aggressive move or
the most aggressive way to play
but those are very important moments in
chess that are taken for granted it's
like well you all he did was offer a
queen trade it's like well if he didn't
do that
he probably would have suffered in the
position it would have become
increasingly difficult to fend off some
of white's plans and thus
could have caused a losing game so i
actually think that this is a moment
that we should give credit to lars for
recognizing the potential danger
and by roberto's time management right
now he is
really in the think tank and about to be
at one minute and now lars might be
thinking
wait a second i thrive in bullet maybe i
can play for more despite the board
situation being one that
should be equal and you know you might
say wow queen you know before not so
impressive
well it caused roberto to think for like
two and a half minutes there robert so
i mean that's that's just a testament or
proof right there from roberto himself
that that was a very strong move
and he was probably trying to figure out
a way to avoid getting a super
passive position you don't want to sit
and have a defensive rook against your
opponents attacking rook
and that's why he was just trying to see
do i play g3 should i play rook b1
first what's the right move order and g3
was his choice now
lars has a bit extra time let's get look
at this move king f7 we're getting
into an end game let's bring that king
to e6 i actually think that
white's position is more difficult to
play right now yeah i
i'm pretty close to just saying like
queen d1
um keep the queens on the board and try
to play against that last move king f7
say like
oh you know you're trying to cut the
line basically um trying to get to the
end game one move ahead
of the end game itself and queen d1 just
keeping the queens on the board maybe
makes the king look a little silly
i like that idea and for lars now he has
to
weigh that well the d5 pawns on attack
can you really play king e6 here
after king e6 white actually can't keep
the queens on because queen d3 is met by
e4
oh actually is there a bishop g4 check
there wait a second
wait if i can keep the queens out i'm
keeping the queens on exactly
exactly there is bishop g4 check i
think but even if there is
and that's not established yet um a
black could just move the king back
it's not so clear that's true you can
just move the king away and say maybe
you've committed too much to keep the
queens in the pick go back to g8 and say
okay well now you kept the queens on
gotcha
what's that called you know castling by
hand is a thing what's that called when
you run your king in the center and then
run it back
i don't know we got to come up with that
almost it's almost like a
like a suicide at a track meet or
something like that
is it yes who's that sprint there yeah
it's yeah it's uh
tough to give a true name to but 12
seconds left for roberto this honestly
is lars's time i would even consider a5
right now
just trying to be as advanced as
possible in the position and maybe
there's king d6
in the near future trying to bring the
king into c5 it seems like a joke but
if i can get my king over to the square
c5 i'm
ready for this end game 100
100 and even as we start to get into a
potential end game
like uh trading the queens the king is
also just closer to
running to the the queenside pawns so
even trading queens becomes a serious
option
and rooksy too well now that bishop
needs to stay put because knight g4
would be devastating
three moves how can black rook a2 i
think that's
probably the best way to keep that pawn
on a7 safe now rook a1 okay once these
pawns come off i don't think there's any
danger for white
yeah i'm trying to think about
how things could go wrong a black sort
of has the draw
if he wants it with rook b1 rook b2
because i don't think that the bishop
can move as you pointed out
but uh you know he obviously wants more
than that it's five seconds for his
opponent
as you said this is where lars is going
to play this game on
maybe there's some kind of rook b1 rook
e1 and try to create a meeting
if that knight can find its way to f3
that's a very far way away but i know
that if my knight gets to f3 and my rook
gets to b1 i could try to checkmate
the white king in there so okay wait
rookie one coming
yeah i don't know if i'm there's rook c2
after rookie one i don't know if i'm a
big fan of
g4 not at all as a move because even if
the rooks trade now
there's there's something to play for
wow f3 what a move to play with four
seconds in your clock
but if you take knight takes e4 this is
looking scary knight g3 check is a fork
the king comes in even as well yeah
there's a lot of good ways to take it we
have two broke up two one piece
oh my goodness you wanted this rookie to
check king c rook f2 oh no
d5 is hanging oh gosh yeah the d5 pawns
hanging
now it's a draw again oh my goodness
yeah even though this is not beautiful
for roberto this is uh
um this is gonna be a draw
yeah this is sufficient here although
you know if you take on g4
and white takes at the wrong point there
could be a losing king upon you but here
you take and then create opposition you
need to be able to create opposition not
be in it to begin with oh don't take on
g4 yeah do not take on g4
one second he barely got that move off
what
oh my goodness and it is a draw knight
he's gonna play nine of five then he'll
take on a five if he ever does that so
so if he can he's looking for king f1
king like h2
and at the right moment you sneak that
pawn by
what would that want to eat no way
yeah so i would have kept the king on
g3 and waited for this shuffling that
white's doing with the king um
because then it could work yeah knight
f3 just take it and king f1
[Laughter]
he's going away
that's funny
oh no that was a fun one look at roberto
he's stressed man he he just
he just breathed out a heavy sigh of
relief again
so these games are getting to him and
you want to know who's
uh not stressed lars he he never looks
stressed
he always looks like bewildered is the
best way to put it
well then i can't tell is he always
stress or is he never stressed
one of these situations where it's one
of the other because
he does look bewildered he has he's
wide-eyed trying to
see through these positions and look at
this opening once again
we have a wild start to the game when
lars has the white pieces so when
roberto's
white we get some calm approach maybe
let's trade some pieces i'm gonna try to
outplay you
from large like no chill let's just go
for a pawn launch
and see what happens yeah like uh i
think when lars
is playing he really tests the chess.com
opening theory book um and he really is
trying to
find out whether chess.com has a name
for all the openings that he's
that he's bringing out here like g4 uh
all right chess.com
what's this one called that's actually
really funny and
at a certain point there's no name
you're like all right that's the lars
that's
that's it'll have to be it'll have to be
and what is going on here because black
is trying to crack through on the
queen side and it looks like white at
some point will play on the king side
but white can actually castle king side
black has no pieces over there
so even though you pushed your pawns to
g5 and h4
cast on king side should be safe for
white and castle kingside for black
could get you checkmated yeah you can
castle
uh king side despite the pawns being
pushed
yeah i don't know about that one giving
of the f6 square man that seems
risky let's let's go with risky
yeah we'll call it risky call it even um
he does castle kingside
despite you know knight getting in we
understand the movie h6 it's like hey
he wants to take and after pawn takes
he's got the the open file but
the moment that knight is covering the
h2 square
and i was about to say knight g4 also
covers h2 and prepares
what he is dying to play which is knight
to e5 followed by maybe f4
wow if you could get all those moves in
that's just probably strategically game
over
i don't see a way to stop it well knight
d7 stops knight to e5 but can you start
taking on the queen side like
i feel like that side of the board some
kind of take on
i don't really want to take on c5 though
see that's the annoying thing because i
want to open the whole queen side but i
want to keep control over an e5 square
and i know i can't get everything that i
want so
need to time this kind of thing
correctly i think taking a b4
might make some sense um you know if the
pawn takes back you've got the c file
and if the knight takes back you
temporarily get the e5 square i don't
know if you can make use of that though
and instead lars plays the com rookie
one but there could be an e4 in the near
future trying to open up
the position against the king on e7
although wait a second is that bishop on
b7
so there must be some tactical sequence
and i see the eval bar just
jumped out of my periphery there and now
knight takes d4 maybe
yeah d4 is is loose he's gonna start by
um trying to open more lines with pawn
takes
on c3 but uh yeah you immediately jump
to that bishop on b7 and say look the
knight's in the way
got a hanging rook on or loose rook on
e4
take that knight and drop it wherever
you want basically
and yet taking the pawn d4 in the
process looks great and
actually looks just unstoppable
and there's lars sitting and thinking
but maybe a little bit too late you
should have
thought before playing e4 spent only 1.5
seconds
playing the movie e4 and now he's deep
in the think tank trying to figure out
is there a way to survive this
and it doesn't look like the answer is
yes and that's
that's such a common chess player thing
it's like you play really quick and then
once you've played too quick that you
know you might be losing it's like okay
well let's spend the time and try to get
out of this
whoops yeah queen takes c3 which gives
it the d4 pawn for free
uh knight takes d4 the brook and e4 is
hanging
where do you even move that rook i think
is he playing this
no is he playing his sack um well he's
plenty of sax something i guess
is fair to say but i was wondering about
rook takes d4 and knight takes d4
probably necessary but then we trick
bishops on g2
and i think that white's king is in
worse shape even though black's king is
in the center
yeah temporarily after bishop g2 king g2
you have a threat of
knight c6 to win the whole game but it's
it's
super temporary you know you make a move
like roxy at the end and then you say oh
well my one
thread is out the window and lars is
good yeah lars is trying to figure this
out here but it's too late and roberto
still looks really stressed like
somebody hit that guy some fresh air
yeah he is racking his brain right now
it's it's incredible like they're
they're both obviously incredibly
focused but
roberto just looks like he had a death
in the family or something like it's
it's
it's looks serious it's just how much he
wants to avoid these tactical games i
get the feeling and
he said that in previous matches where
you know his style is to trade against
the end game play solidly
and he has no choice playing against
lars and the thing is it may be a 3-1
lead after this game it's still
so early and in the back of his head's
like wait a second i got to play bullet
against this guy he's
fast he's sharp he's tactical and so he
needs to save his nerves for when
the moments really call for them and
that will be the quicker time controls
and and you know we uh obviously
probably do a good job of underselling
how
strong roberto is at calculations
um and tactics because you know he he
doesn't hang in
games with uh you know very strong
tactical players
for no reason at all like his king's on
e7 and
somehow he's the one getting the upper
hand in these uh these skirmishes
so definitely a very accomplished uh
player in his own right
and able to calculate as well or
often better than his opponents e4 was a
slip up by lars and
look how quickly and look how
efficiently that move was punished
down on the clock is lars and down on
the board absolutely
that is something that is good to point
out it's not the players either
are bad at what the other prefers it's
just a preference a stylistic choice
so lars can play end games at a very
high level he's an international master
for a reason and highly rated
but it's not his first choice if you say
let's get a position on move one without
queens on the border with
two queens on the board he's taking two
queens on the board and on the other
hand roberto saying
oh queen's off the board yeah let's do
that thing let's get to an end game
so it's just a clash of styles and right
now
lars is down well he's half the time
that roberto does less than half
and it's still looking good for black no
way to break through for white no attack
that i can see
and so it does look like roberto should
continue to take this game but all of a
sudden the knights on e5
maybe there's queen f4 to f6 black does
need to be a bit careful here thankfully
for roberto he has the time to calculate
yeah and um that rook on e4
is there's so many sequences here like
the rook on h5 is loose from the bishop
uh c6 is now targeted square
for the knight to jump in supported by
the bishop on f3 knight d5
looks to me like a nice inter mezzo move
because you hit the queen
and the queen seemingly has to move to a
square
that watches that g5 pawn but it doesn't
and looking at rook g5 and
wondering what i'm missing uh the answer
is probably nothing and where's that
king going
the knight on e5 is also yeah wait
you're just losing everything's just
hanging
right that was a slip up and actually if
we just show really quickly i think that
if lars like queen to d2
instead of queen of b3 there he like had
a chance in this game because
if he had played queen d2 the pawns
protected that rook's under attack on h5
the a5 pawn is under attack
so the queen is doing all the work and
black's position
isn't that simple to figure out so i
think that was a missed opportunity by
lars
it was just not a great game from him
we've of course seen
much better and maybe he just felt out
of it but amman before we had to break
at our halftime break in the five minute
portion what are your thoughts about the
match so far of course roberto leads
three to one
but how have you seen this match come
along thus far
uh i think i'm seeing it develop almost
what i would expect we see that roberto
is the higher rated blitz player
and we've also seen from match's
previous that lars generates a lot of
his points
from the bullet section and i think he's
also the type of player that because of
his style
you know not the most sound openings
maybe slightly dubious it fits his style
but
i think that takes a little bit of time
to get going you know you're not just
gonna
show up to the the match and just play
brilliancy
right right off the bat so i think that
type of style takes a little bit of time
to get going
and uh you know he's obviously hoping to
do a lot better in the bullet so
it actually is progressing much as i
would expect i don't think either player
can be too disappointed at the moment
but lars
does need to find his footing from these
openings agreed partner sometimes our
blessing is our curse and the tactical
prowess of lars oscar hogg
it can come back to bite him when he
gets too tactical he gets too rushed
to break the position open and that's
what we saw here in this last game
on that note we are going to take a
break and return we'll have more from
chess.com's
i am now gm speeches championship
[Music]
so
well we know there are two people paying
close attention to this match it's not
you and i
am on it is greg and levy because the
winner of that match
takes on the winner of this one and well
what do you make of monday's matchup
between
greg and levy both of whom have been
impressive thus far levy's matchups
being
quite close to against the semi-finals
and greg having the odds match in the
first round
and then against costia just a
three-point victory for him so
who do you see as the favorite in
monday's matchup
well i think uh if we're talking about
who has the momentum right now
it's gotta be levy roseman aka gotham
chess with
you know his his recent uh performances
in uh chess.com blitz and bullets
especially
he's gonna come in i think the higher
rated player in
uh maybe both categories um robert so it
definitely looks like on paper
you know levy the levy train is is in
full force and i just have
i'm having a flashback right now to his
last match against the
eric rosen which was you know prime time
special so
obviously excited to get into more stuff
like that that was
one of my favorite events to commentate
ever that was so much fun we had the
call together
we were losing our minds the players
were nervous and
we will see levy move on to face greg
who of course
has been a mainstay a strong blitz
player for so many years
however we're in the middle of this game
we see a repeat
of the third game of the match roberto
going back to this line
in the queen's game decline playing
bishop e2 trying to leave black with the
isolated pawn
but we didn't really like what roberto
got in that game
what do you think he'll do differently
it's a good question because
uh for the opening moves and this is
sort of proving my point i don't think
there's much to change
so up till now it's the exact same game
um b3 and bishop b2
is something that i thought he would do
you know multiple points during that
last game or the last time we saw this
opening
he's actually brought his knight from
the center back to f3 which
is a very strange move to me
yeah that's is strange
but it's just trying to avoid trades i
guess and
yeah it doesn't feel right but he's
protecting his king
and now he puts his bishop on a3 with
tempo so i'm sort of at a loss
of what's happening here but i don't
mind it for either side honestly
yeah bishop a3 is with tempo but when
you're attacking that rook on f8
i mean every single time black plays
this opening he's going to grab that row
from f8 and put it on e8 so
neither side is you know too phased by
by that little maneuver
bishop a3 rookie is exactly what lars
would do anyway
look for this light squared bishop to
make an appearance either on
you know f5 or the more aggressive g4 um
but bishop f5 played looking to control
the center and uh
rook might appear on c8 i mean you
pointed it out and the eval bar backs
you up
0.00 basically both sides doing well
here
and i like the bishop on a3 because it
takes away queen d6 which is often a
nuisance
setting up the battery for a checkmatic
attack knight e4 the knight just went to
a4 so i might as well take
this square that's available to me and
now knight c5 let's trade knights
and when you see these trades being
offered the palm b7 is under attack so
black has to react in some way
but white is happy about this you want
to blockade the isolated pawn
so you want to make sure that black
can't push d5 to d4
and if that bishop gets to c5 well for
sure you're not pushing that bomb
right yeah if the the pieces trade the
bishop
blockades on d4 i think that roberto is
uh he's gonna be pretty happy with that
now the pawn is
hit on e7 and you know an attempt to
guard that with rook b8
might also be met by uh knight b7 and
i'll show you right here like
uh this is a very typical uh maneuver
you play rook ba thinking you're
covering the threat
and the guy just does it anyway and i
don't think there's anything more
disheartening in chess than
protecting a threat and then your
opponent just does it anyway so
right that's why he captured they always
told me to look for
undefended pieces i defend it but then
it's a secondary layer right you take
the pawn to remove the defense of the
knight
and as you get better and better chess
you need to be on the lookout for these
things
and well look at this oh okay i didn't
like that move i'm on because i thought
rook
e6 first i was about to say a rook lift
people missed brook lifts all the time
and lars i think should have started
with rook e6
and then figure out does the rook go to
g6 does it go to h6 but either way the
queen can join later
but the rook now cannot join because the
queen's in the way
yeah that's a great point um starting
with the rook i mean basically take that
rook on e8
place it on g6 or h6 right now that's
where it wants to be and the bishop is
doing a great job on e4
contributing to the attack f3 g2
but also contributing to defending that
isolated pawn in the center so it's a
great anchor if you want to
kick that bishop out at any point you
know bishop d3 in the future bishop f3
you can also just leave the bishop there
in lars's position and say hey take me
bring my my isolated pawn even closer to
your king
and yeah knight d4 was a very good move
because now in the event of some kind of
queen h4
why can i move f4 so that knight on f3
while it was defending the h2 pawn
directly it didn't allow white to push
pawns forward and you may say
wait pushing pawns forward in front of
your king that sounds bad but it also
allows your other pieces to defend for
example the queen on d2
will defend g2 once the pawn moves out
the way in the bishop as well so
i actually think that rook e6 first and
we talked about this
leading with rope was good knight d4 a
fantastic response
by roberto yep and the
time again seems to be uh the classic
case of
the guy who's the better bullet player
is lower on time
i don't this is becoming like a
widespread uh
i guess phenomenon that the the better
you are at bullet
the more comfortable you are letting
your clock tick down
because your you know two minutes to a
good bullet player is like
i got extra time you know i this is too
much time
whereas uh you know roberto who's
obviously a great
bullet player in his own right but
probably
isn't counting on scoring as many points
in that section as lars could be in this
match
you know he's always been up on time
from what i've seen so far
yeah good start to this match from
roberto in this game
no exception to that i was starting to
wonder i was kind of
daydreaming about some greek gift
sacrifices now it's not going to be
possible because white
is going to play f4 i believe to cut off
that bishop but i was just thinking
was there a bishop h2 and then a bishop
g2 and all that kind of stuff
i don't have the answer to my own
question i'm guessing the answer is no
because lars
the great tactician he is would have
played it if it worked out
yeah it's uh something that he would be
looking for at
every turn and you mentioned the move f4
there it is on the board and this can be
a really tough move to face because you
know what a lot of times in positions
like this
robert it lack is required to make a
pivot from
full-on attack to oh i'm actually now
going to transition into just playing
this game normally
maybe capturing on d4 going rook c8 you
know nothing
nothing too special and that might not
be in the style that lars wants to play
and this pawn e3 that looks like a
backwards pawn but hey there's a bishop
on c5 so that pawn is actually
very well defended and bishop d4 piled
pressure against this pawn c6
there's no attack that i see at least
not at the moment for black and so for
white you can start
attacking and putting that in air quotes
on the queen side because there's some
weak pawns that you can try to
put threats on and win yeah
bishop d4 i mean queen g6
piling up uh on g2 so speaking of
threats take the air quotes off because
that's an important one and bishop f3
looking to trade some pieces
however with all these bishops come off
i feel like white has to be
pretty happy with that development rook
c6 there goes that pawn
just down the spot i think you can take
it
there maybe i'm overlooking some
tactical sequence with bishop f3 or in
queen b
no i don't think that works i think rook
takes c6 is just
a pawn you can grab and that's a very
important pawn it's not just the
material but then white can have a free
attempt at a pass pawn on the queen side
with a4 b5 in the future
and keep in mind uh you know something
like bishop f3
rook takes f3 there would be um you know
bishop takes d4 might be an idea to take
on e3 and
fork the king and queen here is a
discovered attack but the rook on f3
perfectly defends that so
there's just no tricks as you brought up
it it almost feels like lars played that
move
instinctively thinking that there would
be some of those tricks queen b1
bishop takes d4 but because there
weren't any
um in the position and it doesn't appear
to be roberto called that bluff
immediately with rook c6 now lars is
fumbling for the next
the next move here and you get
frustrated when you overlook
these kind of simple moves oh my pawn
was defended by the queen the bishop got
in the queen's path
now i just dropped the pawn and he's
down almost two minutes
he only has a half minute himself and
this is looking like it should be
roberto's game but
it's not over right black can play on
here it is upon deficit that's no fun
but just
keep going and you need to play more
quickly because otherwise you're losing
the clock as well
yeah and rook c8 um i'll just point out
you know rook
takes a6 for example uh you can see that
evaluation bar just uh say goodbye as
rook c2 and you're threatening rook
takes g2
and coming in with a very lethal uh
check meeting
so pattern can't allow that rook to
infiltrate so
do you take on c8 perhaps and just start
trading those bishops off
is that a way to go though rook c2 is
still going to be a bit of a nuisance
maybe you trade on c8 and like rook seem
one yourself
because of black's back rank checkmate
problems but okay roberto
answers the question i would i would
trade on
e4 and then you can trade on c8 and go
rook c1
or you can just go roxy one but trading
on c8 and rook c1 um
does seem that seem pretty reasonable
though if you trade on c8 rook c2 isn't
an immediate threat which is funny
because it looks like it just wins the
game
because white has this rook c1 resource
so it's just
funny how these things can happen i just
wouldn't even want to think tactically
so like rook c8
uh i'll show rook uh see it rook c8 and
then
you know imagine white just tries to
debate him it just goes like h3
and you know rook c2 rook c1 is uh is
robert's idea
the idea of course you can't take the
queen he's a back rank mate
so you just want to see these things and
just remind yourself hey wait there's no
luft for the black king so there could
be a background checkmate and actually
this is a good illustration
of that because the e3 pawn if you take
with the queen on d4 it looks like you
could win the pawn e3 you cannot there's
background checkmate but i like what
roberto is doing
thinking at this moment i'm actually not
sure what to take with
probably the pawn takes is better
because if you take with the queen
there's a queen b1 check queen takes a2
check
that looks like a lot to calculate so
pawn takes d4 is probably the best move
i just like that roberto spending some
time but he's about to dip maybe
into too much time queen b1 queen takes
a2 with check
would probably be enough for me to not
play that on the spot
um and he does it wow
i was with you i was not giving away
that pawn
i mean listen it's not a not a mistake
but uh not a huge blender but
i don't i think he takes was preferable
and watch out now because queen f1 is a
big threat so king f2 played
and where's that king maybe he's not
running anywhere maybe he's accepting
that
it'll be a repetition maybe they're both
accepting that it'll be a repetition
if you're lars you must be thrilled
you'd straight up blundered upon c6 that
was not a sacrifice that was a blunder
we saw by his reaction
and yet he still was able to hold things
together and he was down
almost two minutes on the clock yeah no
that's a great point and there's a
reason why uh
one of these players is shaking their
head at the result not both of them
yes and he's still mad he needs to we
all
need to do this when we play a match we
need to get over our previous games the
problem is in a tournament you have a
full day
right if you're playing a classical
chess tournament you lose a game or you
draw a game you're winning you're
frustrated you say
i'll eat i'll sleep prepare for a next
game now it's like
next game going yeah you know snap and
you have to
get right back with it and look at lars
he doesn't give you any time to breathe
he is threatening checkmate of course
roberta's not going to allow the
checkmate but do i take on g5 and then
allow that bishop into the game and
castle's queen side or did i play g6
which was the choice
but now there are all these potential
dark square holes
on the king side so no rest
for the tactically weary roberto molina
yeah and it's basically just uh lars
he has this style that puts on
relentless pressure
in the opening um this line is clearly
something that lars is familiar with
it's a little bit off the beaten path um
just going back and showing this move
bishop e2
is not one of the most common moves here
i think this is
an important game an important moment in
this match because
we all know um from previous matches
with roberto
how fond or not fond he is of the carol
khan
he he plays it as his main weapon and if
lars gets you know great positions or
starts crushing him with this opening
that could do a lot to roberto's
confidence and
uh he mentioned that in the post-game
interview of his last match that
because his opponent was able to get
such a good position against
uh his karo khan speaking about lawrence
trent
uh he was actually thrown off during the
match he was indeed
and right now he has what looks like a
dream position whenever somebody
establishes d4 and e5 pawns
you want to break down the pawn chain
with the c5 move and he's accomplished
that
and knight c6 is the next move the thing
about this i
i see the evaluation bar saying black is
heavily favored
and roberto has plenty of time he's good
experience and he is a great player
but what i think about where is that
king going for black if white can
somehow
maintain the pressure then that king
never finds true safety
and even if the objective evaluation is
oh black's doing great
practically speaking you always feel
that not in your stomach of wait a
second there could be some kind of
sacrifice or some checkmating attack
and so roberto needs to figure that out
yeah and speaking of sacrifice
um you know i'll just show one of the
common ones that you're always thinking
of
h6 you know if you play that without
thinking too much
well hang on knight takes e6 is always a
big idea
um and queen takes g6 to follow up
bishop takes h6 is in the position
he might just run the f pawn queen takes
e6 as well like
this is how positions like that fall
apart uh fall apart for black
that's true and so roberto moves his
queen out to b6 i like that move a lot
hitting the knight on b5 hitting
protecting i should say the pawn on d4
and now a4 is played so a6 would seem
the logical follow-up
and white is going to play knight d6
check so you've encouraged that knight
in here
and i've always found these positions
amman to be
extremely challenging to evaluate i get
the feeling oh black should be better
you have a pawn
and then you're like wait how do i move
from here i can't castle queen side
f7 falls i can't castle king side there
will be some big attack
especially with those exposed dark
squares do i play e5 which
for now is safe but a rookie one happens
and maybe bishop moves in f4
breaks open the position i'm never sure
what move to play
even if i feel that the position should
be good for black
and if if people don't believe you what
was funny is that while you were saying
i don't actually know how to evaluate
these the evaluation
bar wasn't sure how to evaluate this it
started going up and down without any
moves being played
like it even takes the engine time to
adjust the positions like this because
of everything that robert pointed out
there i mean the king
we need a decision which way are you
going e5 in the center
and after rookie one is it gonna be
something like f6 allowing the knight
into e6 it just looks
it looks like too much you gotta gotta
put the king somewhere
yeah i grimace at the thought of f6 uh
if the knight coming to e6 scares me
then i go to c7
wow grimace away knight e6 king f7
and uh that wow
that is impressive that knight is very
scary
and 96 just king f7 and the knight goes
to cease
i don't know how to evaluate this
position i feel like
you know i i know i can see the
evaluation bar off the side over here
when i tilt my head this way
i see that black is doing well but i
would roberto doesn't know that he's
trying to figure this out he probably
thinks
okay i have a good chances here but he
doesn't know with any degree of
certainty that black is in the driver's
seat
and i don't know what move should be
played even if when i do see that the
evaluation is good for black is it king
f7
is it okay king of sun was played and
queen h3 and i see the evil bar kind of
going up a little bit for once i don't
know what to do
i i have no idea it's that kind of wild
position i
think i would play the move i would not
take the bishop that's for sure that
scares me too much maybe i should do
that i'm not doing that
the queen on h3 lines up against that
knight on d7
uh rook would have the open e file that
looks pretty scary
i just also don't know what else to play
though yeah maybe i mean
there's at least knight g5 after taking
on f4 with the queen getting
right involved in the position that
looks like
it cannot be good that's no
uh it's probably i'm guessing it's one
of those positions that's gonna be like
oh it's a draw because of some weird
you know saving idea for black that just
forces white to take a repetition it's
like one of those types
but it doesn't look good i could also
see why just winning in the next few
moves
what other moves come to mind besides
about like
i want to move my knight somewhere okay
oh look at the evil bar i saw the
skyrocket so i was going to say move the
knight
from c6 as he did somewhere and then
knight c7 i want to play queen d6
so that that's the general idea is that
you know all saka in exchange to get rid
of that pawn
however right now i don't think it's an
exchange and
bishop takes e5 i don't even think it's
going to be night move at
all oh my goodness knight g5 he wants
he wants knight g5 he could probably
even play rook take
okay not probably just does it just does
it don't need to tell him what to do
and d6 queenie is you have to play that
move yeah because pawn takes e5 with
knight g5 check coming your king is
getting mated
in the near future so i think queen
takes d6 and
just put your hands together uh talk to
uh kaiser there and say please help me
survive this game because
you're oh no way well no that's
who you need to talk to right now oh
knight g5 not the move
you know that means f4 was the move like
bringing in another f4
f5 what a okay but queen e6 like i
will i don't think i'll be satisfied it
must be rook f
eight no rook f8 loses immediately yeah
the queen e7
like i said i am not convinced that
black survives this so
if he he does he deserves everything
he's 18 seconds left knight c6 like
queen
d7 the only check where's f7
oh finish did you think about that but i
like the
evaluation bar it's like doing jump rope
knight f7 check i like queen e7 because
you kept the square open for that knight
takes e5 check
just keep taking things with check
where's that king going after king 60 of
knight g4 there has to be a mate here
of course king f6 there's maybe f4 as
well
oh gosh yeah okay knight g4 i mean
i actually don't see a mate just yet
so it looks like there has to be
something
what do you think about h3 that's just
some move like that i like that i like
h3 especially because roberto is 10
seconds left it's 10 seconds that's the
other thing is that practically
it's winning as well an h3 queen g7
queen h6 you protect them
that's oh that's super clever i like
that
i i like h3 for that because i was even
thinking about queen g7 right now
as i'm you know hey take a step forward
if you're if you're that
uh you're that ballsy but i think
h3 is probably the way to go look at
lars eyes by the way
yeah he played h3 yeah great move
this evaluation bar is not
no idea what it's doing it's been at the
bar too long it's got it's got to go
home
queen g7 threatening mate and one queen
h6
and after queen g5 i'm sure it's knight
f6 check which
uh okay knight of six where's the mate
though
so knight f6
g5
knight f6 king g5 f4 king
f5 g4 king e6
oh a queen d7 decides oh my gosh
we oh my gosh well wait robert just one
second by the way he's gonna lose him oh
he doesn't lose some time
f4 check here's the mate coming exactly
what we were talking about oh and
f4 king h4 king h2
that's beautiful that's so beautiful
that's filthy oh my gosh there's nothing
you can do about it
oh this is just g3 here it comes king of
oh he lost some time but we have to show
look at lars's face
oh my gosh if he got that move off and
i'll go back and show you guys
so many cool mates there in that
position
so um before we get into the next game
we got a show
king h4 king h2 uh
if nothing else robert tons of style
points
sacking your queen and checkmating with
a pawn
the knight the f pawn everybody working
the king's involved you don't even need
that rook over there
and the other one we were looking at was
king f5 g4
check king's only got one square queen
d7 check
king takes knight and then another pawn
checkmate that's just
you don't you don't get attacks that you
know capitulate with pawn
checkmates uh all the time robert no
that was
a gorgeous tactical sequence and you
could tell that lars was feeling it and
honestly what we're talking about we
know the evaluation bar at first was
saying black
is doing well and i'm sure if you just
switch on the engine
look at the suggestions there are ideas
and moves for black to survive
but practically speaking it's just
beyond difficult in a blitz game
so lars really earned that one and for
roberto i don't think you have to
stray from your karakana i mean he was
doing well he's going to get a break
after this portion i would just quickly
you know
text a friend or turn on the engine and
to review that game
okay i could have actually survived and
had a good position if i'd done these
two things
then you feel better about going right
back to that con
robert would after getting checkmated by
a pawn
immediately text a friend hey
i need emotional support and i rely on
my friends i try to be open i talk
through my feelings i'm on yeah
your support support system for those
tough checkmates
it's good to have one of those around
yep we all need friends
and lars by the way he's is he up
he's a pawn in this position yes but
there's a bishop pair that's staring
towards black's king yeah it does
not it actually looks like if you
reverse the names
that's the position i would expect them
to have um
lars has actually been the the greedy
one here he's gobbled that center pawn
and you talked about rook lifts well how
about how about an assisted rook lift
i actually was going to say i loved the
move bishop e4 that was a really good
defensive move
but i liked the response instead of
taking on e4 doing anything you just try
to improve your rook
but knight f5 is so frustrating because
now your rook lifts don't look quite as
good
the d4 pawn needs some attention and
oh how to proceed g4 for white that
looks quite risky
but i could see that panning out and
watch out for d5 at some moment as well
opening that bishop up so
just like the other game the one we just
saw this is a situation where
sure black is probably having a healthy
position according to the engine
but practically speaking there's so many
tactics to keep an eye out for
and whenever the evaluation uh is around
equal guys like whatever is right in the
middle of the board 0.00
but one side is down an entire pawn
it means that the other side has exactly
enough compensation for the game to be
level
and in positions like that usually you
want to be the side
down upon um you know if the game is
equal but you're down upon it means you
probably have a great position and
i'm a huge fan of the d5
punch in and then loosen up that f5
knight
and get like a rook f3 rook takes f6 and
you can immediately
go get these like super dangerous
checkmating ideas
yeah i'm with you there and i like queen
c2 just keeping an eye on the a4 pawn
why did black play the queen d8 sure
rook d8 can happen but also that pawn
was under attack
bishop a3 is an idea because that rook
on f8 isn't so happy there and
b5 by lars i think bishop a3
will be met by knight d6 and
looks like black can hold on to the
material for now
yeah even still it looks like the type
of position where even if bishop a3 won
the rook
you'd almost be unhappy to do it because
you know
you you see a position like this and all
you want to do is go rook f3
d5 you know sack for something on the
king side
here and i actually think the move b5 by
lars is
very resourceful a very strong move like
if that gets taken twice
uh the reason that roberto is thinking
so long i'll just show you
let's say we capture everything um that
square on d5 is what it's all about and
i wouldn't be surprised if knight d5
first instead of queen
b5 was playable but you get the idea the
knight sinks in
and that bishop on b2 robert is not
participating anymore
and roberta did play bishop a3 so uh
we have similar names and he goes well
we actually have the same name just
from different places and so bishop a3
played the rook on f8's in trouble
and he just takes back on c4 after lars
talks the d5 square is blacks
however you have to sit passively for
the time being
and there's that first rook left and
don't be surprised if the second one
joins the party with rook d3 and
swinging it over to f3 or g3 probably
one of the funniest things that
i see in chess is when when you double
rook lift
and then somebody threatens back rank
mate it's like wait
i can't get out of it my rooks are
blocking my two pawns so
that's the one thing to watch out for
when you double rook lift
is that a simple back rank threat can
sometimes just be like force mate
that's true and i'm not sure you
actually have anywhere to go
with that second rook perhaps one rook
can do
the job and bishop c1 at some point
comes to mind i like knight e5 bringing
your piece
back towards the enemy king and i was
saying bishop c1 to sacrifice an
h6 but if i move bishop c1 then knight
frees up from e7 so it's so
tricky position where black has an extra
pawn
white has the current initiative but if
you're not quick it feels like black is
able to
get out of this and claim an advantage
not just a decent position
yeah and you know i i'm looking at the
move f6
now that it's available the knight moved
out of the way f6
kicks the knight on e5 out it also opens
up just generally speaking
you know another avenue for the black
queen maybe queen g6
especially bishop c1 would be a
consideration
agreed f6 such a difficult move for
newer players less experienced players
to go for because they're told never to
push in front of their king
but then knight e5 is just frustrating
black
and if that queen can get to g6 as you
mentioned or the rook up to f7 to help
defend
it brings in more resources for the
black king so
right now this is the tough question i'm
on where to go
because white's pieces seem pretty
optimally placed
perhaps the rook on d1 would like to go
up to g3 but you were just talking about
how that could lead to a background
checkmate that you
for example actually rook d3 rook b8
there's already threats of queen takes
a4 in the near future because of this
very background checkmate so i'll
actually show that that's a
good point if you swing the the rooks
over there queen
takes a4 as robert pointed out this is
exactly what i was talking about
these rooks that make it so that the
king can't escape it's like
a suffocation yeah you can't go all in
and well roberto plays rook g3 and lars
plays f6 so we're
right on the mark amani and knight g4 i
think the threat is clear knight takes
h6 maybe he'll blunder
that and if the knight moves from e7 the
rook on f8 is under attack so
not that easy to make a move and he just
says ha i'm cool
let's slide the king to h8 no problem
yep
yeah now knight f5 is not quite possible
because bishop takes f8 followed by
bishop takes g7
with a check um h6 though
threat renewed and like i just pointed
out knight f5 is not exactly possible so
maybe your queen h5 type of move where
you use the fact that the queen is
opened up but there could even be a
knight takes h6 there like giving up the
knight to play rook h3
after there are a bunch of tactics to
figure out
thankfully for lars he has a lot of time
two minutes 26 seconds
and just plays rook f7 look at that
knight f5
is such a big threat now that the pin
has
been removed from the game um wow knight
f5 is so tough to deal with
and not know if i for sure is about to
happen has to
well he's thinking which means he might
take that pawn in a4 which i wasn't even
looking at until he started thinking
like why could he be thinking here now
he plays knight of five
and now he'll take on a4 i think so now
uh e6 falls but d4
is hanging everything falls yeah the
thing is the attack
white is kind of like queen side bishop
kingside knight
rooks are like half in the middle half
attacking every piece is kind of doing a
different thing
in this position robert so yeah queen a4
as you mentioned queen takes d4 it feels
like white's game falls apart here
especially with 20 seconds
great response to bishop c5 and queen d7
quickly
dropping that back i just don't see how
white can attack the knight on f5
the problem for white in part is you
need a pawn and an iron g4 at the same
time you need to kick this knight out of
f5
and you can't do it so rook a3 probably
a good positional move just trying to
double and attack that pawn on a6 and
maybe that's what roberto needs to do is
give up on the attack
and just go for that pawn we're gonna
see at some point like
an h3 just a move from uh roberto if he
doesn't have a move
he's probably just going to throw that
in 93 looking to trade
a6 pawn being pressured i think roberto
is doing a good job with 10 seconds
um but lars has the advantage here no
doubt and nice quick reply there
after knight f4 threatening mates on g2
just
f3 blocking the queen and now this a6
pawn that's falling right queen d3
and if you lose that pawn your king
isn't perfectly safe and you only have
one extra pawn for black so i actually
think that roberto
is doing a really amazing job at fending
off the immediate threats and then
trying to
honestly among what i guess i want to
say is changing from aggressive plans to
defensive
that's a really hard switch to turn on
and he did that mid game with no time on
his clock
agree agreeing queen e4 he might even be
looking for more here
just forcing the queen tray taking a6
next and on 92 check
look at that king f2 just making sure
you don't drop the d4 pawn
very very quick now a6 drops um
one thing to watch out for is maybe
knight d3 um
black is still up uh upon which is why
his position is still favored here and
wow look at that
look at that how quick was that sequence
and i think that's a
fantastic find by lars super impressive
it really is
now d6 is falling so black is going up
two pawns
the e4 pawn light square you have a dark
sword bishop
not going to be easy to defend that one
after knight g5 kind of sequence
this should be winning objectively for
lars and on the clock
as well c4 great follow-up move and
you'll find that the pieces just invade
here knight g5
is pretty much the end of the game
taking the e-pawn and i think he sees
that now
same idea and we'll actually get one
more game in this time control when this
one concludes
and for lars he is the momentum for
roberto he played
really well at the start of this match
and he's playing well it's not like
that's the problem it's just he got down
on the clock and he was down a pawn and
he couldn't quite figure out how to
proceed
and lars came came right back
in this uh in this match it's actually
been
rookie for maybe just trade okay i like
rookies there it is
yeah yeah but this has been a big
comeback from
uh lars since the break uh robert he
basically
came out of the break at a different
person
he's improved the i don't want to say
new but definitely the improved
compared to the first four games of the
match so lars
is ready to go and this is a bad sign
for fans of roberto molina because we
know how strong lars is in bullitt
roberto also very strong but in the
history
in the first two rounds of this
tournament
i think lars like a 15 to five score
something
like that something crazy but it is
three and a half three and a half
tied match we have another karo khan
this will be the final game
of the five minute time patrol and amman
do you expect to see
some kind of crazy position like we just
saw two games ago
yes yes i do
i think lars is not going to change
a line where he had like and lesbian
lars saw those checkmates
at the end of that last game he just
didn't get a chance to play them because
his opponent flagged so if you have a
game like that
uh trust me there's there's a part of
your brain that says
i'll just repeat it and we'll play the
exact same game and i'll checkmate him
this time
you know he's he's going to go back to
those positions because
look how well they worked it's no longer
a choice you just have to do it wait
queen h6
see bishop we just saw that position
i'm not you know he's he's just checking
maybe he might actually just take a draw
why not he's
made a big comeback already i think he
probably evaluates his bullet chances as
pretty good wow okay well he takes the
draw by repetition
and i like that decision for both of
them for roberto you
score half point after two consecutive
defeats
for lars you can say wait a sec i know
what i did
landed me a victory a smashing victory
with a checkmate
but perhaps there's something there's a
flaw in here and to have the
self-awareness to question your decision
say you know i won but
that looked a bit sketchy let me
actually go look that up
i think for both players this was a very
mature moment
yeah i think that um roberto doesn't
have a
as much of a choice um being black and
also after queen h6 you sort of have to
bring the bishop back so um i think this
was
an interesting decision but i don't
think it's that crazy as i said lars
scores a lot of his points in the bullet
portion can't forget roberto has
like a crazy high bullet rating like i'm
pretty sure he
came in at like 28.50 or something uh
ridiculous last time so
do not think that this is like a lars
gets the bullet
and wins the match type of thing but
it's just that's where he has gotten his
points in the past
that looks as though he's comfortable
with the draw get to the next portion
and get to the bullet probably the best
lars has done
in the first time patrol with that it's
in the books
we will take a break and when we come
back we'll come back for more of this
4-4 match-up between
lars oscar hogg and roberto molina
[Music]
so
and we are back ready for more from
roberto and
lars amon amman 4-4 score lars has the
momentum he's won
a few of the last i think two and a half
last three games to even this match up
who do you think is happier that the
break just took place
uh it's a good question it's sort of
funny because
we don't see a lot of breaks um happen
right after a peaceful result like that
it seemed like both guys are actually
pretty reasonably happy to go to break
but obviously i think
lars is going to be very very happy in
general to be done with the five minute
portion i think when the time control
gets shorter his style gets better um
and that uh you know he likes to go for
these speculative sacks
and the you know slightly dubious
openings and i'm here for it
i think it's a great style especially in
online chess and i think it works better
when your opponent has less time to sort
of calculate everything out
and figure out exactly what you're up to
and we're back
in the games here oh an e3 we're not
getting the vienna with e4 we need to
get
in the title of this opening right three
nights vienna
quiet variation so quiet variation
i think we know who chose that one and
it is roberto once again and by the way
i looked up their bullet ratings during
the break
lars is 2820 bullet roberto is 28.01 or
something like that so they are about
even in terms of bullet so it's going to
be a
tight match up to the very end yeah it
is going to be a heavyweight
matchup in the bullet portion right now
though we've got the three plus one
section so
i would say a time control that the
players always feel a little bit more
comfortable with
there's still that plus one robert but
three minutes is what
everyone is used to playing online
that's
true for sure and it's what everyone
plays and the
ignorant makes a difference it allows
players who make flag in other
circumstances gives them
some time to build and here lars plays
for e5 so roberto got an e4 but
after dropping his bishop back to d3 and
lars plays e5
and to my eyes d5 is the natural
response try to keep that bishop on b7
locked in
that bishop on c1 can go to g5 in the
near future
i think that white's spatial advantage
is not to be taken for granted
but what do you think lars anticipates
from this and he wants to blockade
the deep on first but i still like white
yeah white's position looks good it's
that bishop on b7 because
especially in this position there's some
a little bit of a different dynamic
that you have to watch that a pawn so
you can't just bring the bishop back to
c8 and reroute it
to another diagonal like you normally
would and if you play a5
you're giving up a lot a lot of light
squares in your position so
i understand lars is coming with the
knight to d6 he's going for the trades
but
very simply you can pile up pressure on
the c file here for white
and maybe even go for something like a5
bring the rook to c1
slow gameplay knight h4 into into f5 is
another
idea to try to play on both sides of the
board but i i echo with what you're
saying here this
looks very comfortable for roberto
um right out of the gate it's funny you
just mentioned a5 and i was thinking how
both players probably want to play that
and now black
can play a5 which means that there's no
pawn hanging on the square
the downside of playing a5 you give up
control of the light square so knight d6
first but once again i know white went
work a1 to b1
but i do believe that a5 still is a
pretty promising move
from white's point of view yeah if you
wait and play
b4 first for example um they might
follow bishop e3 and then maybe a5 from
black as an option
just to take control of all those dark
squares on the queen side
we're definitely going to see that after
the trade i don't see another
appealing move besides a5 gives you the
c5 square for your knight
allows your rook on 8 to be more active
and if white plays
b5 after black plays a5 you shut down
the queen side
and it's black who controls the pawn
breaks on the other side of the board so
lars
does play a5 it taking makes sense he
can bring
a rook to c1 uh for roberto he'd simply
use bishop b5 but knight c5 would be my
very quick response
i think this position is easier to play
for black what do you think i'm on
yep agreed not a big fan of the b4 move
for white
so that's what i would have omitted
going forward
if i was playing the position but knight
d2
he's swinging that knight over whether
it's to b3 or c4
um i think that uh lars has a very easy
game though he can slide the rook to a8
from f8
he can now we talked about that bishop
couldn't move earlier now there's no uh
a6 pawn
well look at that move bishop a6 there's
also bishop c8 to d7
same idea it's funny i knew you're about
to say bishop a6 because you said he
could now and then he made the move
so i knew you were saying it before he
played it and that bishop can even come
to
d3 plant that bishop there the e4 pawn
starts feeling a bit uncomfortable
the rook on a5 is actually a strong
piece that knight on d6 if you're not
careful we'll hop into c4 if you move
that knight from d2
so i think bishop d3 and maybe f5 to
follow
breaking open the king side instead lars
plays g6 a bit of a
quieter move and now knight b3 we
mentioned this idea for white so i
thought that you need to be a bit
quicker
for lars and well i'm registering maybe
neither of us need to move too quickly
well it's the quiet variation robert
both players are echoing that here with
g6 f3 just some slow building moves uh
f5
by by lars definitely wants to happen
and that bishop on c6
um not to be underestimated because it
stops
both rooks from going to a8 so if the
action is on the king side
it stops black's rook from joining uh by
a8 you know and moving over to kingside
and if the action's on the queen side
the rook on f8 can't join so it's like
kind of a funny
piece here but it disconnects both of
the rooks very effectively
and on the flip side of things it
actually blocks white's access to the c
file you want play rook c1 and pile up
against this backwards c7 pawn
but your bishop is stuck there so it's
funny that both sides are happy
and unhappy about the bishop's placement
but look at this the board is opening up
queen f2 necessary because otherwise
queen c5 would be a check that picks up
the knight
on c3 i would still consider queen c5 to
get into
an end game but then again there would
be a knight e4 to follow maybe a punch
through with d5 to d6 and the b6 pawn
gets weak so rook c5 does make sense
although 94
a kind of natural response attacking the
rook yeah
has to be the immediate response
basically his rook on uh
a5 was not doing anything had to
activate it
decided look you can have an id4 with
tempo i want my rook
doing something off the a5 square and
wow
whoa tactics coming out here knight g3
to e2 or knight d4 to e2
okay so knight g3 to e2 coming our way
but
white's position looks pretty good i put
my queen in e3 just to cover
all the dark squares around the white
king
you know king will go to h2 after 92
check and isn't
white's position better because the pawn
on c7 is the easiest one to target not
easy
but easiest relatively speaking yep
i definitely feel that way
this c7 pawn is going to be a big issue
i'm not sure if lars is properly
estimating that because queen c3 is
coming up after bishop b7
and the problem is that if you think
you're trading e4 for c7
the c7 pawn is more important because
the d5 pawn is passed the b6 pawn
becomes weak
and maybe okay rook c6 he leads with the
rook that way when queen c3 happens you
take on c7
and pin the black queen to the one and
queen c1 is possible here
for example that rook is pinned oh my
gosh the bishop is just hanging out
nice nice fine and there's no queen g3
there's no discovered
checks discovered anything with that
rook it might be bishop takes h3
just because you have to do something
desperate times desperate measures and
he plays it
can you take takes with the queen and
i'm going to
check to be careful about that 10
seconds so how do you deal with that
maybe just brooke no queen of four's
named a threat because the bishop on b5
covers f1
so you could actually play d7 yeah but
as kenji won okay
that move makes a lot of sense queen if
look at this defense though great
defense covering d1 threatening queen f8
check and make the queen of fate
okay it's still very good for white but
he went the wrong way there
rook d8 is a great move does rook d1
okay bishop
one only move you found it it's a big
move
before bishop b5 just win that b6 pawn
and push the a pawn king
king to f4 though king g3
sometimes the bishop and pawn can be a
little clumsy but rook a1 is huge
huge this is so roberto right putting
all of his pieces in defensive
before he goes in the offensive and look
at this the pawns in a7
here comes the bishop although how does
the bishop get in put it back on
b5 and go to c6 it's almost
gonna go rook c8 yeah oh
god e2 oh my goodness e2 oh it's a
thunder splendor and you
don't go for game one okay one oh my
gosh
oh good move queen click on f1 and then
rook takes number b1 you get
the check on the third rank wow this
might be a draw somehow i think it's a
draw
what a game what a match this has been
yeah this is a draw for sure
yeah with the g pawn you just leave the
king on g1 and
this is why you learn your end games
everyone you can do the
first ranked defense with the g pawn
because the rook if it goes e2 to h2
there's no way in look at roberto
both of them nobody's happy with that
result
no and what a game roberto had the win
lars turned the tables by finding this
tricky move
after tricky move bringing that king
into g3 threatening mate
and i think the problem was roberto got
too cautious
when he could have gone for a checkmate
or just pushed his pawn immediately to
bring his rook
and his bishop back and i get why he did
that
it just did not pay out for him in that
game
yeah there's always going to be these
moments where a certain style is going
to be better at executing a game
there's lots of cases where you know the
more solid approach and i can relate to
this because that's
my approach i'm always the no counter
play type of guy but sometimes
you have to make that you know important
decision
to allow a little bit of counter play
but you forcefully calculate your way
home
i was listening but what is this
position yeah good question honestly
you were making a very good point and
i'm listening to you taking it in and i
agree with you that
people believe that playing risk-free
chess is the safest right playing super
solid but sometimes it's actually the
riskiest way to play
and the position may call for tactics
what is happening here
what is this i think i was trying to
mask
how weird the position was with with a
sort of mundane statement like
yeah you know so people just try to do
it's like let's just
glaze past this opening phase maybe no
one will notice that
there was a bishop h6 knight h6 played
by roberto
and then a you know h4h5 and a g5 played
as a response and
hey guess what queen trade being offered
and no
see this is interesting because roberto
would have probably played like knight
g1 to e2 to leave the queen trade on the
table or something like that
and lars has no queen trade and now e5
happens
and that's the thing is you keep the
queens on the board and you don't
actually
maintain what advantage the engine
evaluations seem to give white
because black has this really strong
center yeah
knight e 2 traps the bishop
knight f3 allows a fork so he has to
play this
weird move bishop e2 and not what you
want
the black king has not moved right so
you can still castle king side if you
want not sure you want to do that
and white can technically cast a queen
side
not sure you want to do that either so i
do not know where the kings are going
and queen g3 check here there's knight
f2 the e3 score is defended by
both the knight and the queen so you
don't actually land a knockout
there although it's just good to put
your queen in
on white's camp i think bishop e6 just
defend your d5 pawn makes sense now
i just am confused as to what's about to
happen we don't know where the kings are
going we don't know
if the kings are going we don't know
anything the the black king is so
exposed there's only short castle
i have a feeling it might stay in the
center however you can short castle as
long as you
do not take that g pawn um taking that
jeep on here
and short castling very bad combo well
looks like we learned a bit more
information about white's position as
well he will not be long castling
and look at how quickly roberto
responded he had that lined up he
expected
rook a6 and that's what happens over a
long match
is you come to be familiar with your
opponent's style
and the moves they might play so you
essentially can pre-move
much better as the match goes on and
okay queens are off both kings are
safer i won't say safe because there's
still a lot of open space in front of
them
and knight g4 so trying to distract the
pieces from the c6 square and just from
the queen side more generally
yeah understandable um i wonder which
piece he's gonna take with i can see a
case for both of them here
bishop takes g4 you know has the idea of
bishop e6 to follow up
the only downside of bishop g4 would be
giving the d3 square with check and then
maybe a rook f2 to follow so
that's a good point goes in this move
order and bishop e6 probably is too
greedy
because of knight oh he goes for maybe
it's not but i thought knight d3 check
the king gets up to e3 wait how long
knight d3 i'm gonna play rook d8 next
i just pin your bishop rook d8 yeah and
there's no king e2 because of knight f4
yeah we're bd8 that's it oh
that is not that is not even good at all
bishop takes e4 now
that is doing well that's a huge miss
yep and this king on e3 is not happy
though i'm confused man
i'm going to be honest with you
chess is hard
i i see think that
black is doing fine here the knight on
b2 looks weird with the pawn c3 is under
attack
what's white's best move now though i i
have a feeling this is the type of
position that if someone's gonna
end up on top it's probably gonna be
white um
this h-pawn in an end game can be very
annoying getting h6 some back rank
issues
uh bishop takes e4 played rook c3 and
king d2
so uh the bishop on e4 is great it can
coordinate with this rook like rook h6
or rook a7 which is exactly why rook
c7 was played and do not blunder rook b6
attacking the pawn
knight c4 oops i actually think that
white's position is
look at 20 seconds by the way even look
at the clock black has a good chance
here because white's king
is in worse immediate shape and there's
20 seconds for lars
yeah and those rooks are starting to
staircase together
right like rookie 7 the king will run
away f2 and maybe castle at long last to
g1
but it was a long trek a beautiful
journey though
king the g1 and i i think white's
position is starting to get
pretty good like the the rook b6 move
can now happen
h6 is one of those annoying pawns you
throw up the board and
that black king is never never really
able to join the fight
yeah h6 would be a nuisance to deal with
you probably need to bring your knight
back that night on d1
it's reached the other side it doesn't
get a promotion so let's uh just
bring it back with some kind of knight
c3 with tempo or maybe
e3 just creating some threats and does
choose knight c3
bishop f3 very solid covering all the
squares the knight could move to
of course it's an option to take that
but i think yeah
mars is looking for a little bit more
here he is and
what about rook b8 and then pushing that
b pawn can i get away with that he
pushes it
first by the rook yeah i thought this i
guess he
push the b3 and
i i think of rook on b8 here would be
amazing for
roberto and h6 he wants that pawn there
very annoying rook b7
starting to be some threats although it
looks like black is able to just
put a rook on d7 to fend off that attack
on the h7 pawn
and here maybe even throw in king g8 at
some point but i understand
leaving the king in the corner just no
checks available is that rook takes d4
as an option here i don't know if it's
good enough you you get the h7 pawn but
remember the g
pawn and the h1 are so disconnected it
might not be good enough
well look at this in comes the knight
around here but the b3 pawn about to be
lost
you don't want to lose that pawn that's
for sure and you have no choice now
i think you have to go knight d4 and
trade the knight for bishop and just
maybe draw the end game but
now this is getting risky there's no
knight g4 check
no and i could see a stalemate by the
way the king has no moves knight f1
and the knight g3 yeah and rook d3 if uh
king h3
oh gosh and um rookie three
that was the worst blunder i think right
the b3 bishop is hanging as well
and then rook d5 or something like that
maybe make g3 now
wow you're hitting everything that's a
good response
take d3 if you take you through rookie
five and there's knight d
f6 and the knight g8 go knight g8
i get the feeling this is probably a
draw but it's a
really weird position yeah because the
pawn gets the g5
then yeah you know the knight can't move
now it's a dead draw yeah rookie eight
just pin the knight and
no moves yeah it's funny black can just
give up the rook and stalemate
that is worth doing i would take on g5 i
would take on g5
and now he's gonna do it with check no i
wonder if he's actually trying to play
for a win because he's double piece
but obviously there's you can't move the
knight it's actually impossible
yeah give him the rope all three of
these things over here h pawn king h8
knight g8 they cannot move not a single
one of them so
oh no fun
we have a lot of respect for the players
they're playing a great match but come
on if you're gonna make a draw don't do
it by repetition give
give us the stalemate we've all been
hoping for and you see the players on
screen roberto thinking
what could have been where did i go
wrong lara's just still looking
really with intensity at the screen and
roberto actually seems
very upset right now yeah he's i think
he's just
experiencing that that um you know
that expected emotion after so many of
these games
seem to end in draws or you know lars
was down to like 10 12 seconds in this
match
uh and he had almost two minutes and
he's just not converting them so i think
he's
he's just uh got high standards for
himself and he knows in this match that
every point
is gonna count it's a tied match uh as
we have the break here in the three
plus one portion and you know it could
come down to a single game
and then you're gonna start to really
reflect on the matches which he's
probably thinking about right now
for sure he had that knight d3 check and
maybe that rook d8 pinning the bishop
i'm sure he's thinking about that
tactical sequence
but all in all it was a well-fought game
there have been ups and downs trials and
tribulations
errors and brilliancies but we are going
to take a break when we return we'll
come back with the second half
of the three minute plus one second
increment time control of this roberto
lars
i'm not gm speeches championship match
brought to you by chess.com
[Music]
we just want to remind everybody of the
format for these matches
there are 75 minutes of the longest time
control you've already been here you
know about all that we're about midway
through the
three plus one time patrol we'll get to
bullet but right now we're so
locked up with such an even match you
want to remind everyone of the tie break
format that if this match ends the tie
we get to a situation where they play
mini matches four games of one plus one
and if it's still tied we get armageddon
among you and i we don't
root for players we don't really root
for results but how exciting would it be
to get all the way to armageddon well i
you know i don't even have to imagine
how exciting it would be because we've
already experienced the
craziness in tie breaks like we had the
tie break between
eric rosen and levy rosman and i don't
think we quite made it to armageddon but
based on how thrilling it was to even
play those mini matches and extra games
with all the pressure
uh i think that uh armageddon would just
be a treat
yeah it would be absolutely electric and
right now we have
another vienna quiet variation we've
come to respect this
and roberto did have a very nice
position two games ago so he's going
back to this
lars has felt at home in this variation
it does give black
a good degree of flexibility with the
minor pieces
but white can control the center so who
do you think is going to
blink first are they we're going to see
this all match yeah
i i guess the question is and it's just
been answered are we going to see bishop
d3
again from roberto i think that this was
a great
opening for him but i don't think that
he proceeded
in maybe the most accurate way so e4 e5
was
their previous game and i think that's
repeatable for roberto but obviously
lars you know he had a great position
he doesn't mind repeating either and i
wonder what the players did during the
break because sometimes you
look at chess i need to improve my
opening figure out where
i could get a bigger advantage or save
myself when i got in trouble
other times i just can't look at chess
anymore i'm in the middle of a heated
match
and bishop d2 was played we saw bishop
e1 type of ideas
in the first game of the match uh the
stuff it was the first game overall if
i'm not mistaken
and so yeah here's bishop e1 once again
yeah it's kind of interesting because i
feel like he's combining
his two ideas from both games but
previously he had bishop d3 and e4
and in the first game he had bishop c4
with
uh you know bishop e1 and then black
took on d4
and here i think he's probably going to
take with the pawn and play the game the
exact same way as he did before but we
look at what lars has done
differently he did not play rook d8 and
then go back to e8
he can get knight d5 because there's no
bishop on c4 so there's a few things
that are a little bit different here
robert
that's right and also bishop a6 it seems
like hey wait a sec that pawn still
hanging
there could be a bishop takes f3 which
would force you to take with the g
pawn not very good or there's bishop b3
to go win
your a pawn so it's not that simple here
for
white to figure out this position you
should probably not take
on a6 i wouldn't go for that i'd play
something calmer like bishop c3 that
feels like a
roberto move hey let's trade on my terms
if we're going to trade darts for
bishops
right um well we're in the quiet
variation and rook a1 is totally a
quiet looking move um that's dealing
with your bishop b3
idea of forking those two pawns and if
a5 happens to save the apon here for
lars
it gives up the b5 square and that's the
square that white can pretty permanently
look to occupy
and look at lars go look at the d file
there are minor pieces
on d76 and d5 staring at white's king
side bishop c3
that's an isolated pawn so you're just
staring into your own pawn
bad bishops defend good pawns so they
say so i think that
both sides are just trying to figure out
how to proceed from here i
like black's position though yeah agreed
um
looks like there's going to be easy play
for both sides here in terms of where
the pieces go
95 that's uh you know an automatic
looking move
get in the middle of the board and now
that apon
it's something to think about bishop
takes a6 now a lot more of an idea
because the queen can no longer come to
g5
after the knight f6 move and the knight
is no longer on f3 so there's no bishop
takes f3
um it takes a sec yeah you just said i
think queen b7
was a good move for black defending a6
and attacking g2
bishop a6 he grabs it i'm trying to read
lars's expressions he's just eating
so i can't tell how he feels and he has
the best poker face ever because he's
always
astonished he said bewildered and okay
now i think we're getting a little bit
of a tell from him i don't think he's
very happy that he dropped the a6 pawn
but for the most part he does not react
yeah it's true um i mean the uh
it almost looks like so roberto molina
is
probably shaking his leg because he's
nervous but it looks like he's in a
massage chair
yeah he's got one of those nice gaming
chairs that could double as a
sound like it's just shaking behind you
yeah maybe actually
it is a massage chair that would be
pretty cool and probably helpful
but you i think you're right that both
players are trying to figure out the
position we saw a trade there on
e5 and now white has the bishop pair
so i think that bishop e1 retreat you
could play bishop d4 as well if
you want to be more active but bishop e1
feels like the robertson movement
instead he just
allows us we should be capturing saying
i'm up a pawn don't mind
liquidation takes takes pawn is going to
get to
c4 um bishop's kicked out
extra pawn he's going to take it slow um
and lars that's you got to chalk that up
to just a blunder
completely overlooked his apon and
that's the difference in the position
right now
yeah that was not a sacrifice sometimes
it may be a dubious sacrifice but we all
make those
that was just a blunder not recognizing
that that pawn could finally capture by
the way
18 seconds of counting down for black so
it's a difficult position down a pawn
and you're down under 20 seconds but
somehow lars
when he's in time travel he's the one
who almost plays better so
something about this match so far lars
has been able to handle the time travel
but right now rook d4
push one of these pawns take over the d
file
this can't be good no not at all um
rook d6 however
v6 rook d2 not the direction you want to
take this position
no that bishop on b5 just keeps control
over the board take with the pawn
i play rook d4 just give me king f2
the rook on aid's useless right now
yeah the bishop on b5 sort of uh
anchored by
and anchors these pawns so it's like a
nice
trio that keeps the rook out of the a b
and c files
and look what roberto is doing okay i
didn't like that move i thought he was
going his king to b4 i thought and he's
bringing his king up this side of the
board but i thought that
king d1 move was a bit slow but maybe it
wasn't and he's just
figuring this one out yeah he's he's at
least on the same page
it's gonna be a5 because hang on that
rook comes down to c1 and
lars is going to be annoying he's going
to be annoying here
very and how does white proceed because
you're up a pawn
but the rook covers the b pawn the black
king of course keeps the d6 pawn in
place uh kings
the rook went to b7 a vital tempo
yeah i think it's just ooh can't you
take the pawn now
then rookie two check and then you name
it
that's funny so what here rook b4 to c4
something like that
look at this and king b7
wow now the king gets over king d7
is the try here no fast is lost
yeah and that's end game technique for
you by roberto and
lars hoping for some pre-moves but
roberto has 50 seconds left this is just
an easy win at this point and with 20
minutes left in the three-minute portion
portion roberto
takes a lead once again he started off
the match up three to one
then lars came fighting right back
tied the match up it's been tied for a
while now a one-point lead
for roberto yeah let's see if lars can
bounce back and tie this match up again
he has changed his opening
against roberto's karo khan so he's
going to e4
c4 and we've actually we're actually
getting a position
very similar to the position that
roberto gets as white
so we've seen this before for example
knight back we've seen this exact thing
these guys clearly have positions that
they like and look at this
because he's playing with the black
pieces not the white pieces he doesn't
get to play bishop a6 aka bishop a3
that's a really good point and is
honestly just the same position colors
reverse but a tempo ahead for white
that's how these things work
and right now the position looks very
nice for lars
his style of position and roberto needs
to be careful so knight a5 a great move
trying to keep the d5 square defended
and plugged
you just want to make sure that the e6
pawn feels safe sometimes there are
sacrifices on that square ripping the
king open
and roberto doing well on the clock lars
keeping pace
i think that for now i like white's
attacking chances
but as the game continues and the
isolated pawn remains
i would favor black in any potential end
game
and look out for knight takes f7 just
generally speaking oh gosh right here
knight takes f7 i think 97 was
was it i think i think it was winning i
i think it was it
was about to say if there's ever a move
where the knight
leaves that square knight captures f7
we're hitting the queen
bishop takes e6 follows for example king
takes well
bishop takes e6 and you're going to get
mated in a couple moves here there's no
question about that plus
you don't even have to find mate you can
just play b take c3 after and it's game
over
yeah that was that's a pre move let me
check the time
he did not pre-move it he spent 1.4
seconds
but he is going to regret that he must
see that
that he had the opportunity to sack the
piece go for the e6 pawn now after
bishop f6
the rook on e8 defends the e6 pawn so
sacrifices
may be in the air later in the game
certainly not the case now
and i would okay but c4 no this is
turning i would say in black's favor
no the yeah this is not uh this is not
right
for sure because that d-pawn
c-pawn all loose normally you want pawn
on c3 not c4 number one it guards d4
supports the center number two
laughs at himself
[Laughter]
oh my goodness oh my gosh
lara's blundered the mate and then lars
is laughing and roberto is like stressed
he's like
grabbing he's pulling his hair out like
dude you just made the guy
oh gosh well that was something and you
know lars may kick himself about missing
the knight takes f7
he just allowed checkmate in one move
and you know we we know that pain we've
all blundered these kind of checkmates
and we're like oh how how could we we
jolt back but for lars at this point
you've lost two games in a row
you need to really gather your bearings
just say i can do this
i was just even i missed an opportunity
maybe he doesn't even realize he had
knight six f7 just yet
but i blundered checkmate in one in a
perfectly normal looking position and
all right we're into this next game here
i like roberto's position once again the
isolated pawn
i don't particularly enjoy playing with
it but something about it
is to lars liking yeah and this is uh
as we said last time this is a repeat of
the exact same position
um we've seen this before bishop takes
e2 it's got to be knight takes e2
um i'll just point out the difference
here if queen takes e2
if that was played then the d for knight
would simply be hanging because of the
rook on e8 so you can just go ahead and
capture that
that would be a free piece so of course
he he had to move the knight back it's
not the move he wants to do
but um it's the move that was required
here so
he's just oh he plays bishop takes f6
robert and that's a
committal decision he's going to grab
that pawn and look to trade pieces
and greed is not always good because
that rook on d8 can land on the d2
square but for now
roberto's claiming it's not a big deal i
can just move my knight back to c3 from
a4
knights on the rim are dim so let's
bring it back to defend a2 defend the 92
at the same time
white is upon and i see people asking uh
to see that checkmate again we will show
it later we're just in the midst of this
game but don't worry
we will definitely have an instant
replay as we head into our next break so
we'll keep that
game up and we'll be able to show it
later but right now
it looks like lars is in trouble once
again he's lost two in a row
he's down a pawn the next move for white
almost pre-movable is rook f
to d1 then king f1 start trading pieces
and
you're upon hat absolutely
um knight e5 you know an idea
i think it just gets met by either king
g2 or even f4 um
kicking that knight out i'm i'm not so
sure here
this this looks like uh a real extra
pawn for roberto
it does and it's presence doesn't need
to be felt just yet but if you play f4
and king g2 king f3
just the long term advantage not to
mention that you have two knights as
white against a bishop knight
combination
that bishop on a7 will not be able to
defend the pawns on b7 and a6
so if a pair of knights gets traded then
white has
even more of an advantage to go after
some of the pawns
yeah there's no way you can uh just
trade everything here it just
just doesn't work um after taste takes
rook d1 i think we'll see
rook c2 i think we almost have to see
rook c2
yeah the rook d7 though you
had to do this for black but this
doesn't look very pleasant
this is terrible yeah rook d7 is
rook t7 is a lightsaber move but roberto
i
think what he's up to is king e1
and rook c1 like those types of ideas he
wants to force an exchange of rooks
he could almost trap the rook like if
the king could go to d1 right now if the
king of the rook would swap places king
d1 the rook has go to b2 and king c1
traps the rook so
you have to be careful if you are lars
not to even lose the rook but rook c1 as
you pointed out that looks
like a pretty good move here yeah i
think kicking the rook out
is an achievement because if you go king
e1 now there's bishop a5 which is right
quite a frustrating move so uh rook c1
and if rook b2 then i think you could go
rook
b1 and king e1 oh there's actually a
rook b2 because the bishops on b6
there's knight a4
even better that that's an easy thing to
forget that you just brought your bishop
there
that would be a little bit awkward yeah
i was i actually
only just thought about it because like
oh well what's the difference in the
rook moves and then the bishop just came
there
so it would be a mistake and now rook d6
i like that move your rook can go to h6
if white is not careful to win this h2
pawn
and for roberto right now
king f1 back but you just want can you
want to kick the rook out so you
probably don't feel great about making
this move
no you definitely don't um rook gets you
back and he says all right well
what are we doing here we're just doing
a little bit of a tango i think knight
g3 to e4
makes a lot of sense and he plays rook
d1 so we've seen this position before
he's got to be careful rook c1 is
maybe three times yeah i think rook c1
rook d2 should be three time repetition
here
it just was done in a weird order
although i'm trying to check
yeah f1 f4 was thrown in there
yeah f4 and bishop b6 so there were a
bunch of moves thrown in actually
and wow knight e4 allowing the rook to
take a2 because
knight d6 check picks up b7
interesting moment here and honestly
seven doesn't seem like a great pawn to
take
bikini seven is knight c8 so do not play
king e7 ah
very easy oh oh we played it it's so
easy to miss
night scenes it's regarded to see it
oh he's staring at the board he's
getting as much he must see it if he's
staring at the board like this
there's well he i think he might
eventually see it but i don't think he
sees it right now
because he would play it instantly if
you oh we missed it he didn't see it
so i wonder what he was thinking about
there may be some kind of knight c3 to
d5 if you could bring the other knight
in but both players
having a sort of blind spot to this
opportunity with the fork
the the reason that he didn't play
knight b7 immediately is because he
probably felt yeah that's a weird pawn
to take which is sort of what i was
saying
because i missed knight c8 as well i was
expecting king e7 knight takes b7 i was
like is that good for white and
roberto's probably
thinking the same thing he did not even
consider knight c8 and
to be honest robert you're the only one
who did of the four of us on cam here
well you know i was looking at knight
fork earlier so i still had in my mind
maybe there's a knife work somewhere
and black is fortunate right now because
rook d6 check
would pick up that knight of course it
doesn't because the rook defends it rook
d7 check well then the king just goes
back to e8
suddenly it looks like black is the one
who can start playing for more if
white's not careful thanks to this
outside pass pawn
yeah rook d6 keaney seven might see
repetition
i would play a5 from lars just push that
pawn
there it goes and well we have a
little bullet scramble here but i guess
at the end of the day there's nothing
black can do to get out of this pin
except for play king e7 so rook d7 rook
d6 is just a fair i think it's a fair
a fair draw considering that uh lars i
think buys facial expression maybe
maybe uh we can ask him uh later but
i think from his facial expression he
knew there was nice c8 there
yeah i i wonder because he did seem
a little disturbed by how that game went
and
when roberto started spending time i was
like okay well he's got to be thinking
about something
i i don't know exactly what it was maybe
bring the other knight into the game or
something else but missed opportunity
there
for him and he's still up two games so
he should be happy we see the bishop on
a6
and this looks odd to me i don't
typically see games like this but
because you mentioned it
earlier i i just came to expect that
roberto might do something like
yeah there's no way i would ever look at
this position and expect
bishop a6 from black but hey it's
roberto and he's done it
almost every game so far and for lars he
didn't play
bishop d3 bishop c2 bishop b3 this time
his bishop went through
me and queen a4 by the way that's always
a problem with the bishop on a6
but queen a4 i guess you have knight a5
to save the day
ooh he wants to do it this way takes and
then queen a4
there's knight c6 as a possibility
mm-hmm
a seven pawn probably can be captured if
you uh
make some bishop d5 type of move i guess
he's just winning the pawn
and i'm looking now at the eval bar on
screen there it looks like
white's position is quite nice yeah i
think
okay so he goes bishop d5 queen takes a7
[Music]
yeah too soon queen a7 i guess rookie
would
trap the queen but knight d5 first
probably allows you to steal that pawn
a7 successfully
yep yeah yeah trying to like figure out
what's wrong with
nabbing that pun and you know what's
funny is we've seen a bunch of positions
today it's
making me question my evaluation because
there's been a lot of what i would
consider pretty free pawns
um but the evaluation doesn't doesn't
ever seem to
to reflect that compensation is strong
it's the problem with having an isolated
pawn is that even if you lose
upon elsewhere you'll still have the
compensation because that pawn d4 is a
weakness
and roberto right now is trying to
figure out okay i i should be in this
and lars spending his time
looking at the best way to proceed here
and with the match situation the way it
is
with the current dynamics of this board
i think you got to play knight takes d5
right
yeah especially like that bishop is such
a strong piece that
if you let it sit there first of all you
need a good
uh move in like in tow
and also bishop takes f6 knight d7 maybe
that's what he was thinking of
i'm not too sure um knight c6 doesn't
quite
do the uh the job here so he's gonna
trade and
yeah i mean take a seven why not
looks just good you're up a pawn so
the key thing here is trying to make
sure that
you stabilize you brought the queen back
to not allow queen to c2 for example
and i i think queen d1 so he brings the
point all the way back i'm not sure i
would have went
to d1 at that point maybe b3 but the
knight on d5 amana i've had games like
this where i'm like i should be better
i stole the pawn and you can never kick
the knight out of d5
at least not really so where is or how
great
is white's advantage truly it's
uh always hard to realize rook c8
black owns the open file um the queen's
watching f7
he might just throw in a move like h6 or
g6 he goes for
and yeah i mean this is tough robert uh
b5 b4 is also great counter play knight
g4 threatens knight f6 and even if you
get into
queen end game a rook end game there's
always going to be drawing chances for
roberto
that's right i would try to get my queen
son onto h6 but that knight on d5 takes
away both e3 and f4 so
nope no can do rook coming to c2 at some
point
is well right now i guess rook c2 rook
e2 we get a trade of rooks perhaps and
the outside past pawn is what's the
long-term benefit for white even if
currently the position looks quite nice
for for black
rook c1 check keep the c file yeah
i like rook c1 tactically i would say
black is better here just your down a
pawn
like if you put upon a7 black is quite a
bit better
yep but and it's tough because you can't
activate your pieces very easily
each four played maybe there was an h4
idea by black there
so you just place h4 to prevent that and
f7 is the reason why you can't ever
bring that queen
into the action right and if you can't
bring the queen
to the action then at least white has a
bit of time and
well i don't know where white's pieces
should go like rook
e3 to c3 if i get both moves at once i'm
pretty happy
but after rookie three always have
knight d5 so i mean c1
is the idea oh so queen c6 probably is a
good move for white to try to trade
queens and stop that infiltration
and queen c6 hits the b6 pawn tough to
uh
to do something here so he's watching
the c1 square with that move
and knight takes g6 as a threat
yeah knight g6 there's queen c6 but like
there's some times where you just
you know move the knight out the way and
you can get away with it but
but knight d5 played you called it and
now queen
b7 maybe yeah you do you have to play
f3 after queen b7 that looks it's so
annoying because queen b7
you can't just play king h1 very easily
because the knight could
jump anywhere on the board and threaten
checkmate on h1
right so here comes f3 is not that's
yucky
it looks no good at all and yeah i guess
you're going to have too much of a
choice
but after queen d3 that you have to
trick queens the rook on b1 was under
attack ah but he win the d4 point so
this has been a
pretty hard fought game to this point
and now black wins the d4 pawn white has
the outside pass pawn potential
but it's even material
i was going to say i thought we were
going to see another draw with rookie 1
rookie 2
and for a d1 rift d2 and
that would be something and i think
knight c493
um makes a lot of sense okay this knight
check is just gonna go back
okay so we could see a repetition king
of six knight d7
but no lars wants more he plays knight
to c4
and king e2 yeah king
i like that black should probably go
well not now i'd say go for g5
but g5 doesn't work as 94 check yeah
i like the way it's hard to use i agree
it's hard to explain
exactly what's going on to everybody but
a lot of maneuvering basically neither
side has a concrete threat
so both sides are trying to improve
their pieces and their pawn structures
slowly and but surely and every single
pawn move has a consequence so f5 the
knight could come into
g5 for example so you need to be very
careful he does it he
weighs the consequences and goes for it
but look at that
energy five it's a very promising square
for it yep
e4 he's pushing forward this maybe e3
rook d2
um ideas in the position oh i don't like
rook b8 rook c6 was a more active way of
going after the pawn on b6
while it's not anything no this could
turn in
roberto's favorite very quick i mean it
already is turning in this video it is
yeah so it's a time scramble
not much time and look at that he went
rook b8 and all the way back to g7
just to go after the pawn he could have
attacked to begin with and rook takes b2
now
the pawn is pushing at some point very
good though
roberto he's getting that king involved
that's so dangerous
yes there's checkmate rookie tonight if
three only move king d3
then there's knight oh what's easy three
you gave away the pawn under the pun
oh no and king d2 so you have
no you don't have a draw king c one here
he sees it he sees it oh
oh he doesn't see it and look at roberto
saw it he freaked out roberto
oh i'm lucky let's keep going dave
shaking his head
why do they both see the tactic
well it's always one of them sees a
tactic never both of them
right the person who is falling for the
tactic sees it and never the person who
needs to take advantage of it
exactly so what's happening here i mean
there's oh knight e4 is a big move
he gets out of the pin
wait rook g8 oh
the pins everywhere forks i don't know
what's going on one second barely
time for roberto to get his moves off
okay g4 oh barely got that move in time
watch out for the pin
just move your king back they both need
to move their kings this is
wild oh wait that's just falling down
watch out for knight f6 rook takes h5
okay so knight at four metaphor breakage
oh gosh can what
where the rock the
[Music]
oh my gosh and roberto just hits himself
on top of the head
what is going on what was that game this
is the wildest match
right now and both players kind of look
like they're in disbelief about what
happened there lars
you know won a pawn then had some
opportunities missed a fork
that roberto saw and then roberto was
the one of two pawns there then he lost
one
he was losing the second but instead he
dropped his rook
and white had the option to take that
last pawn off the board
and instead just kept the rook on for
one move and black on the rook i can't
believe it
that's really smart bullet play by lars
by the way in that rook a6 move
just saying oh wait your knight's under
attack you forget that your rook is
hanging or don't just don't see it on
the other side of the board
and well lars has changed his opening he
has played c5 earlier
and now look to e8 so um i guess we are
back to similar territory
as some of the other games when he
instead of starting with rookie 8
and he played c5 first i'm still
honestly i'm trying to talk about this
game but look at roberto look at lars
they're probably still thinking about
that last game
i'm definitely still really deep in that
last game
i'm on what to say man uh unbelievable
stuff there are the blunders
are everywhere in this match um and as
we've been pointing out
it seems that the guy who needs to find
the blunder to take advantage of it
never finds it and it's never the same
guy so it's just
whoever that person happens to be
they're just not finding it
um when they need to but the guy's
blundering is always trying to keep that
poker face
uh so you know the other guy doesn't
look at him on the zoo call and get any
uh get any ideas
yeah and during a bullet scramble i mean
mistakes happen like that all the time
so
of course we're not trying to be overly
harsh about the players chess
and both players have been allowing
opportunities that otherwise
wouldn't be available so it's not just
oh roberto dropped his rook in that game
lars is so lucky no
lars has also made mistakes that have
allowed roberto in fact he blunted
checkmate
on g2 a couple games ago so exactly both
players
are benefiting from mistakes but they're
also putting their opponents in
difficult positions and
you have to credit them for that so
right now we have two bishops
versus a night bishop pair the pawn
structure better
for black in terms of pawn islands but
with the bishop pair you'd have to
imagine that
with pawns on both sides of the board
white should be the happier side
and a very small note is that if blacks
pawns
i'd like to move b5 here i'm a big fan
of b5 but if black's pawn
on a6 was on a7 his position would be a
lot better than it is right now and he
does play b5 i think that's great
um even if uh c4 gets played
you have the two bishops the fact that
black gets to get rid of all those queen
side pawns
means that i i think are we gonna see in
some weird way i feel like right before
every break
and right before every uh you know half
time break
we've almost seen a draw like a very
peaceful result these guys
they never go into a break with one of
them having just
lost like tons of games and look at this
just a draw and actually there was only
one moment that i can think of from this
game
as soon as they agree to a draw which i
think we'll see in just a few
oh lars not mounting the draw
immediately plays
rook to a8 that is funny because rook
takes rook
would have been in the media draw and
said lars says hey let's play on a
little bit the pawn e5 perhaps
is the most vulnerable pawn on the board
i agree with them
um the main thing is that white's bishop
doesn't have a good anchor square
because uh you know bishop on d6
suddenly
all your king side pawns are are loose
and
bishop on e3 can't really guard e5 so he
wants to play lars wants to play king f5
attack that pawn you know the rook's
going to swing down a3 and a2
it's not winning but he's going to play
a few more moves it's going to be maybe
an h5 h4
idea and he's going to continue from
there
yeah this looks pretty drawn yeah just
trade pawns there if you win e5 you'll
lose g5
and so that's just an even trade if
black could play g4 then you would think
about it
but even there that shouldn't be too
much of anything g4 just take with check
my bishop can drop back to f2 if i need
to block the second rank
so this looks like a very clear
equal position definitely um
although i understand lara's wanting to
play on it's like
it's almost an ego thing you know if
you're slightly slightly preferred
you just want to play on and remind the
guy i think he's looking at g4 here
um it's not really a big deal but i'm
sure that's the move he's intending yes
both sides
they know that this game should and most
likely will be a draw but mistakes
happen they have been happening
throughout the match you just have
nerves
the tension of playing blitz for so long
and just getting into the bullet stage
of course lars wants to even the score
and for roberto he's played for a draw
in this game
from a very early point so he's just
trying to
ensure that he goes into bullet with the
lead
and i mean this is an understandable try
you know
black has a past bond here uh the e pawn
runs
and basically if you can stick that
bishop on g6
for black then you stop all of white's
bonds from pushing and yeah in the
meantime you do have this one so
again slightly better not much but
slightly better gotta admit
we take these advantages that's for sure
and the g2 pawn hanging so he goes back
bishop f2 i like the way lars is playing
this
just you know you can slowly try to push
forward
maybe f6 a little yeah just play f6
throw that move in
maybe play e5 to push that pawn
it should of course be a draw but lars
is the side with the upper hand
especially now after king g5
yeah rook d4 rook oh rook a2
or k2 king somewhere g3 g1
but it's getting closer and closer to
picking off one of these pawns
definitely some progress
that's right and
i'm wondering like a bishop h4 rook f2
event just solves all of white's
problems immediately
it it looks like uh
he's going to test it regardless but i i
agree with you
it looks like it does yeah rook f2 now
you actually
give up the g4 pawn for the f6 pawn but
once these trades happen
and now it's not double bad pawns for
white against two solid pawns for black
no it's just bishop takes f6 and
rook takes g2 and i guess you draw that
but that's
you draw that by keeping the bishop
let's say well you could take on g2 and
play
king f2 at the end i know this because i
did opposition practice with some
pogchamps
participants so rook takes g2 does make
a draw after king f6 is king f2 this is
actually very instructive
the only reason robert knows this
because of the pop jam's instruction
no no it's the reason i remember it not
the reason i know it but rook takes g2
does force a draw and roberto is
thinking about it and if he plays it it
will be a drug actually did
a stream where 40 i think 45 minutes
here we're seeing just that
i was talking about you want to blockade
the pawn in the most advanced way
possible
but you need to initiate oppositions of
king f5 king f3
if king e5 king e3 you initiate the
opposition your king
g3 or king e3 is fine because the king
is going away from the pawn so you're in
the most advanced square possible
blockading the pawn while still
initiating opposition
and lars knows this as well you know
pretty much the reason he played on was
to get this position right here
hey he's got an extra pun he he showed
off robert he
honestly did play really well that game
just not enough to win let's uh show
some of those moments if we can pull up
the past games just if we can uh the
knight c8 check
uh some people were asking about that we
might as well before we get into things
we can find these games
just in the player history and then and
we can also show the checkmate
in one move that was overlooked uh so
just a one point match this is really
close stuff
we last saw levy rosman and
eric rosen enter a
tie break match at the end it was that
even but
these two players look like they're well
in their way headed towards
an even match down the stretch i see you
pulled it up there so yeah this is the
this was the checkmate that you were
referring to earlier and
we were sort of like chatting about the
game and
didn't really notice what was going on
and
big moment of course we mentioned it in
the broadcast knight takes f7 missed
by lars and then as a result
an even bigger moment missed with just
rook d1
blundering on the spot you see the
evaluation bar disappears
queen takes g2 mate um just forgetting
that those pieces coordinated because
remember it was not
uh queen g5 that was played by black it
was actually an exchange so sort of a
tricky way
for that queen to arrive on that square
that's right always be careful about
bishops on the
feed and keto long diagonal and this one
helped black deliver a checkmate
there was that other game where there
was night fork missed by roberto but you
know you win some
you miss some it happens in blitz chess
we don't blame any of the players but
amman
before we head to break any just
thoughts heading into bullet here
as lars down only one point and has been
very strong in bullet in his previous
matches uh
first of all this match there's a reason
we showed the tie break formula
because uh there's a good chance that it
might be used
um so i think this is going to go down
to you know just a couple games in
either direction
both of these guys 2 800 blitz players
robert so
no joke at all um i think that
each side is loosening up we have a lot
of blunders from both sides so what i'm
expecting from the bullet
is everything we've seen but magnified
maybe bigger blunders uh maybe bigger
attacks
worse opening positions it's going to be
crazy i'm i'm strapped in i'm ready for
this robert but i think it's going to be
a
super close match either way we may
actually get
hybrid you may be strapped in but you
can unbuckle your seat belts for now
we're going to take a few minute break
and when we return the players will be
back
ready for bullet chest so i hope you're
excited everybody we'll be back very
shortly for more from the i'm not gm
speed just championship
[Music]
and the players are trying to win this
match and what's at stake there is prize
money but they're
going to enter the finals against the
winner of greg shawty
and levy rosman gotham chess so amman
you know
of course the players here lars and
roberto they're focusing on each other
on the games ahead and bullet but which
player do you
see winning on the other side of the
bracket well it's the
you know the important question because
this is the other side of the semi-final
the only other match that's
going to be played we know all the
contestants of who may reach the finals
as you can see
from the bracket right here greg number
one seed going in
i think that um you know most people
would have greg as the the favorite
based on his matches especially because
levy was toe to toe with uh canty for
a huge portion of that match and then
with rosen it was more than
toe to toes toe nailed a toenail as they
even went into a tie break
to end it off so uh levy's matches have
been closer
uh but he's hitting new high ratings
right now robert
um very tough match to call but if levy
continues
at the blitz pace that he's going right
now i definitely think that
he has what it takes to take out the
number one seat greg shahadi
and we have lift up i asked the question
cause i said greg was in chat so i just
wanted to hear your thoughts
and look at this we have this g4 f4
against the cairo again
and knight g3 quickly so we liked
largest position when we saw this
earlier it feels like forever ago at
this point
do we think that the players looked at
this at some point or they're just going
based on their history i feel like
they're just going you know i
lars doesn't strike me as a as a look at
things guy
he just strikes me as a go guy you know
yeah i wouldn't say that he is the
theoretician
of this matchup but i like the way he
plays it's just really exciting chess
he drops the bishop back to f2 because
knight f5 would have come with tempo
now knight if i would drop the pawn on
g6 so he did improve this a little bit
and he now plays h4 he's gonna go for h5
and look at him
we have the absolute five head cam he is
right up against the camera
paying attention to the computer screen
actual
knight takes f5 very interesting
decision
okay so he wants the g file to go
against this now pawn on g6
but black can also go against the h pawn
queen h7 bishop e7 things of that nature
and here we see that happen yeah and
i think i think that roberto
should delay capturing on h4
i agree but i'm just trying to figure
out maybe if you could get your knight
to
somewhere to defend g6 that would be
ideal i just don't see a way for the
night to get there
like that's not going to d3 i'm saying
like knight b5 knight a7 knight c8 97
but
you can't you can't do all that it's a
lot to ask
yeah too much so king should probably go
okay trades ropes this looks locked up i
would say
amman you can correct me if i'm wrong i
would say black's position looks better
to me because the pawn f4
but that's not easy to go after either
yeah i think i think it is just exactly
what the engine is describing
a very very even position um
if it gets spicy it's gonna be
you know some sort of c5 break trying to
open the
the position up and black is a little
bit defensive here
as lars controls the position i think
that the only reason we might see a
result is because
this is bullet that's i would say
going to be the case and i'm wondering
which side will push
first lars is down a point on the
scoreboard so you may think that he's
the one who's gonna do something drastic
but i'm looking at five i'm looking at
a4 pawn exactly the c5 looks
like it was ready and can you get away
with taking this a4 pawn that's the big
question
i don't know about that oh but he has
got to give it a try remember the knight
comes back to c7
that's true but queen f6 queen fe like
that
okay trades rooks instead of going for
the attack he decides that
the rooks off the board is sufficient
but the queen comes back to e8 now for
black
well this is very bad for sure
oh this is also that queen go to b5 next
if you're not careful
queen b5 right now hits b2 and you
threaten queen f1 check if the king goes
to c1
yep or queen e2 check if the king is a
queen e2
yeah queen e2 knight d2 but the the
queen on f6 is doing nothing
just queen before like there's not a
single threat for lars
no there's not oh queen oh man take the
queen
[Laughter]
oh my goodness these guys are never
seeing the tactics they need to be seen
there was a queen hanging for free but
it doesn't matter
in a sense because roberto is well ahead
here that knight on c7
is a wonderful blockade and that is good
overall match recognition by lars to
resign
don't want to even waste a few more
seconds he has 21 plus minutes
he needs more games and we actually see
a
i guess a very very uh uncommon opening
the kohli system
you know normally people are getting
that bishop out turning it into a
trampovsky or a london
but instead you see sort of an old
system with uh
e4 played and honestly has to be
considered a mistake
that lack allowed e4 when his pawn was
on b6 this doesn't make any sense this
is
horrible for black and usually there's
this bishop on c1 is out
in the open somewhere but now it's not
and well it looked bad for black but all
of a sudden with the trades happening
perhaps it's not so bad anymore the
bishop one d3 is so important
to the king side attack although this
yeah still looks good i mean the
control of the center the light squares
on the queen side
i would take white's position that's for
sure maybe rook b8
and b5 is an idea
because yeah i do prefer twice position
the knight on d4
very very strong but it looks like b5 is
some source of counter play that that
lars could use
so let's see and it's a
two game lead right now for roberto and
honestly
look at lars go the knights getting into
c5 and b4 that b3 pawn
not looking very good there i could see
this turning in lars's favor
and i already like his position i
definitely agree but
it's just wild to me that after knight
a6 threatening
nothing white decided to go c4 and allow
the knight to
go to b4 so i don't get that decision at
all
well roberto has shown some nerves i
wonder if that's
a part of it he's just trying to come up
with good moves under the duress of time
trouble
and now that there's a pawn in d5 that's
an isolated pawn
that should be good for white to go
after i still think black's position is
good look at that knight coming to c3
real quick
bishop coming to c5 black's piece is
coming to life
yep 96 ideas as well
uh rook e2 knight c3 so it's gonna be
the other night jumping in but
but rookie five that's yeah every
everything is loose here
wow and f3 there's like rook takes at
five so he didn't go for that
and just an extra pawn for black yep
f3 can trade the rooks there's king f8
for
lars if necessary strong bishop on c5
look at that tying the rook down
on d1 and good pre-moving by the way
from roberto just taking that rook first
and now
rookie two yeah the f2 pawn and then
rook b2 to go after the b3 pawn
when you have a bishop vs knight the
side with the bishop wants pawns on both
sides of the board
and i think rook d5 is still good
there's a5 as an idea
um to follow up and that's why he played
rook c2
okay but a5 right you can just take it
or move your bishop out the way rook c3
there'd be rook d3 you don't quite
yeah and you don't quite want to trade
rooks for
for black because the bishop against the
knight dynamic wait he could have taken
on g5
right yeah okay just making sure yeah he
could have taken and said he pushed and
he's still
better but things are 95 though things
are getting very messy now
f7 b6 all hanging yeah king had to
step in to the discovery g6
wow a5 a5 a5 85 huge
huge move i think you almost take it he
did take it now knight c5 and
white is the one up a piece for two
pawns it's
amazing how that turned around and look
at the clock by the way
you have to play this if you're large
but on honestly you could almost resign
oh it's resignable the problem is that
it doesn't matter if you if you lose
this
uh or not at this point it's it's all
about the time
yes well that's a oh hung a rook
well he was mated but well i i don't
think he really saw his eyes
kind of told us that he was oh well that
wasn't right
and well there's still 17 minutes left
it's only a
three-point match and we were hyping up
lars's bullet proud
based on previous matches but it's clear
that roberto came to play today
oh yeah now at 2800 you're you know
you're not getting that reading for no
reason basically he's
playing super super solid and i think it
helped that going
in he had he sort of had the upper hand
so he knows that lars playing from the
back foot
has to play a little bit riskier that's
right and we have a position
here where it's even material white has
a bit more
space the knight can come to e4 for
example maybe you'll push upon a c4 at
some point
but black has no weaknesses to target
honestly these positions frustrate me
because i look at them i'm like white
should be better the engine's saying
what does it say i see the eval bar it
looks like it's really good for white
and like how to break through honestly
playing g4 is a good start rook h1 now
swing up to h7 good work by lars so far
yeah and i like playing 95 in these
positions and taking with the pawn
um at some point you'll kick that knight
out
and the bishop on g5 is so so dangerous
you know there was an f5 move there that
he could have played because the rooks
were hitting each other
so you have to be careful about that
kind of stuff and lars is all in
on against the f7 pawn he just remains
to be seen how he attacks it again
all light squares as you can see all
light squares from uh roberto the rook
on g7
pretty much nullified by the rook on d7
which is central and doing a lot more
look at that yeah great move a3 rook f3
he's just playing very well right now
and rook c7 can happen the rook can just
move away said king c6 first the e3
bishop can be captured
at this point lars just hoping to hold
on and make a draw because
honestly roberto's dominating this game
he's dominating
and i see roberto kind of looking on the
side of his eye i'm guessing he's
looking at the overall match time so
for everybody's awareness the players
they're sharing their screens
with uh the proctors no
nothing's amiss there fair play is being
upheld but they also can see the
you know keep a timer to see how much
time is left to make sure that they're
uh and the players can also and i think
that's a good resignation
these are terrible games for lars he's
got to get better um
the other thing that the players are
often looking at which is why i say the
word poker face
um from time to time is they're looking
at the zoom and that's a very real
strategy
look at the call between you and your
opponent yeah you're both on live
you know cam for a reason uh a lot of
the players have said in the post game
interview
they're often checking their opponents
after every single move
just to see their reaction you know if
they think they played a good tactic
check the webcam what are they what do
they think of it very true because
normally when you're playing over the
board you see that your opponent's
expression just in front of you
and here with the zoom call you can look
at it a lot of players keep it off to
the side
and honestly i think more people keep it
uh open
and closed some people get distracted by
it but i think most want to see
their opponent's reactions to get a
better sense of the board but right now
lars up 15 seconds i like his position
we once again have an isolated queen
pawn
but there's a knight coming to e5 or
maybe back to e4 the rook can go up to
e6 or something
knight c1 well 95
i mean you have to like lars position f4
he blunders that four he knows it
oh he just laughs but it's just laughter
because you're frustrated about
situation after situation not going your
way
that uh that is the worst move to play
there
and it's such a natural one too that's
the sad part
i think black slows chances by the way
like this rook bishop takes h3 next rook
g5 to follow
you be really careful if you're roberta
and you're down quite a lot of time
yeah i think queen d2
that looks strong oh bishop takes h3
take that one
of course oh gosh and that's
that's two pawns right no doubt in my
mind we're capturing that
so it's two pawns for the piece and
white is an exposed king
and white's down under 20 seconds so i
think that lars has a very legitimate
chance i love that move queen f4 though
yeah that's a great move so strong
bishop e2 forcing the queen back into uh
you have a trade now you're down a piece
for real
for real for real it didn't feel that
way with the queens on the board because
the king could get some trouble but now
it's off it's much clearer knight c4
getting the
uh not even hitting the b-pawn wow nope
great play by roberto those knights on
d3 and d4
so strong look at all of white's pieces
they're involved they're compact
nothing's hanging
and the e6 bishop is going down in just
a moment here taking them bishop h5
oh okay rook h4 played now
king h8 now okay bishop h5 now there's a
bunch of chats to get out of this right
rook f6
still the e pawn hangs oh okay or it
doesn't and now 94 perhaps
it feels like black is sort of yeah 7 97
97 missed okay and now it's once again
still something seven ninety seven nope
okay rook takes no rook 65 rook takes f3
is what i was looking for but i don't
think it works out
yeah this rock takes g5 at the end yeah
the knight forks were so close
but not working and look at the amount
of time
it's like roberto's uh he's trolling
because he's he's allowing
lars some chances so lara's like yeah
i'll keep playing this game
but then he's taking so much time off
the clock so it's like it's kind of a
brilliant strategy
yeah just the overall match time 11
minutes left and
they're just going back and forth no
draw to be made and black's much worse
so it's time being taken and your
position's oh wait a second
especially not getting better but the 95
is he holding this take this draw he's
got four seconds i think he'll take the
draw
wow what a hold though by lars oh no
okay that's that's nope can't do that
cannot be playing for wins in positions
where you're losing if you don't take
the draw
oh i don't have enough criticism to give
that decision
that was probably one out of just pure
frustration that you keep
and there was a four the knight loses
defender wait a second
take that knight and now he's up a pawn
so maybe he made the right decision
amman
we gotta stop no but roberto's a troll
because he's gonna draw this game he
just plays
a6 and it's taking more time off the
clock
it is a deep a deep strategy from
roberto oh gosh
my man the deep fake here where
he well he better hold this game then
because otherwise he can't justify it
anymore
but yes it looks like he's holding this
game
this is unbelievable this is nasty and
it's taking so much time we're down to
10 minutes left yeah yeah
it's almost he's almost won the match i
think he's won the match basically
well you need to start the have time to
start the last game so if lars can win
the next
four games after this in nine minutes
and 45 seconds he still will have time
to play that last one and the only thing
to watch out for is like a rook
d2 g4 check and the checkmate but you're
not getting this this is
this is just a draw just repeat moves
okay he's bringing the king there but
unfortunately
there's no uh oh rook f5 yeah okay we're
gonna find
white could have played play it's
already moved 106
we would have had at least 160 more than
that we've been like 250 moves
guys this is actually oh playbook a8
yeah don't take it don't take it oh my
god this is
actually five head roberto this is
brilliant
it is and just keep playing do not agree
for a draw
as long as you don't blunder your rook
you're going to make the draw anyway
oh my goodness move 116.
yeah this is honestly just fantastic
match play here
and there's no way at this point that
white can lose the game
at this point even if he lost the game i
would this is where you just type worth
and just look at him he's just like this
is ridiculous right oh then we got to
finally get the trade
that was you know we were getting close
to fit like he he did
all he needed to do there no he did that
and then more we were talking about 11
minutes left and now we're down to eight
and a half
so he spent two and a half minutes
making the draw that could have been
made
a while back and that's on mars he took
that bishop on e4
which he should not have done yeah i
can't believe he uh even put himself in
a position to draw that game so
you know some credit over to lars there
for that one but
really what just happened there was not
good for
the lars uh camp well this looks really
good for white though this position
i uh yep i like e3 how do you stop the
g6 played bishop h6 is there something
knight d5
knight f7 at some points really close
but i don't think it works
so how to make it work so close
oh it's so frustrating to have this
position where you know you're doing
well and you can't put the game away
mm-hmm and knight c4 okay knight c6
just trying to trade the knights off
like
at this point is it knight f7 knight or
95 queen d5 knight f7 bishop a2 and d5
do you just go like
insane go all in just do about uh
everything
yeah i'm just gonna you know i'm gonna
go like nike five
knight f7 bishop a2 you know
this is me i'm over here robert i'll be
here all day you know
i like it i like the idea um you know
it probably wouldn't work out
objectively but i'm still here for it
and how about take on g6 now oh it takes
on f7
she's okay he'll take on f6 and take on
h7 and then take on g6 he's taking
everything
fair fair so i'm looking at the clock
six minutes
and 50 seconds and somehow the
evo i didn't like that move it looked
fine to me but i'm just looking at the
match clock because lars needs to win
and needs to win just instantly
every single time i think the reason
that knight d5 wasn't preferred is that
you don't need it to play bishop f6
queen h7 and you may as well keep pieces
on the board
you never know when or how you're going
to need them right
the king pasta is more room to us what
the kings on f6
that is queen h5 head right there that
was so smart the queens have to come off
that's why you don't play knight d5
robert right there that's the answer
gosh that was so smart
that that that he was already well
instead of winning the match but that is
securing it
and robert definitely just said that was
queen h5
i've been ruined or you know i'm
kind of ascending to the next level i'm
not sure which one but either way twitch
lingo is
the vernacular has entered i
yeah appreciate that just
wow wow wow roberto has proven his might
from the very beginning
even before the first match took place
we talked to kriker mkhitaryan
grand master from brazil very popular
streamer and he was just telling us you
know we we know roberto from playing him
and
seeing his games but he was just saying
this guy is real strong
he hasn't had as much opportunity as you
would like to become
try to become a grandmaster but he said
to us in a post-match interview that he
wants to become a gm and
i've been very impressed with his level
of play throughout this tournament
i agree i agree 87 and
you know he's just like this is this is
at that point you know you might have
mouth slipped
rook d6 but what does it really
change um doesn't do much for this match
doesn't do much
sorry for this game it doesn't do much
for this match
no and lars he was close
heading into the bullet and just one of
those days where evenly rated players
one shines and one has to say i i don't
know what i could have done differently
this was just a
fantastic showing by roberto so both
players have been excellent we're
getting down to the final stretch of
games here
four and a half minutes not enough time
to erase a
five point deficit and lars has a decent
position right now
just at this point you're in the mindset
of it doesn't matter i lost so who cares
if i win this game
even if prize money the second half of
the prize money is split by one percent
just
you already feel deflated exactly
queen f4 good move by the way but um
knight g4 nitro
real good he4 g3 queen h6 i was thinking
but um probably still available to some
degree after bishop d7
i like knight g4 you have to play g3 and
queen h6 you have to play h4
so there are no options there
okay now getting the queen back you know
queen g3
these these are going to be easier moves
to play and this big three
sorry as you say this bishop one d3 is
so strong like it's
underrated but that pawn c23
configuration
can't cover everything whoa he wants
rook h4 i think but i was gonna say rook
h4
first and then maybe brooke uh she takes
h3 and look at roberto f4 honestly a
pretty smart idea by lars just trying to
win the game
and it doesn't win and f4 says well no
rook
pins for you yeah queen h5 is
threatening nothing and a queen trait
man roberto these queen trades are
they're they're spicy like these are
like tactics how he finds these queen
trades
seriously he's just so on point when it
comes to
styming his opponent's attack and just
trying to trade off pieces to make his
king feel safer
he's shown a prowess in that many times
throughout the match
and looking to keep playing could take
draws i mean it's
totally uh up to him at this point
oh this looks too good for white to just
make a draw king d2 even
play f5 in the near future start yeah
there we go
even though he doesn't have to he's even
making this game last a long time
oh he's probably just going to win the
game yeah right up a piece for
how many pawns just two pawns was about
to be
one and then probably about to be zero f
and rook d7 now
yikes no this is from bad to worse to
just
you know feeling yeah there's nothing
yeah
there's nothing uh nothing to do here
guys this is just a
very very well played finish ooh brick
to f8 check for style point
that's oh he plays it wow
that is beautiful 10 out of 10 over here
10 out of 10. yes that is a
fair rating for that rook f8 wonderful
stuff
and roberto this was closer
than the match would indicate right now
but honestly after
going through 25 minutes of bullet it
does uh queen a5 check i was like what
is bishop of five
it's actually a line but it feels not
that close i don't know
how do you reflect upon this match right
now uh
completely outclassed and bullet um i
think that it was
i think that it truly was um super close
in in the blitz and actually i was
really impressed with
uh lars let's dress so i thought that
going into the bullet
it would definitely be a close match
because i think he needed to keep the
blitz square close
in order to have a chance there but i
think what roberto is showing is that it
does have the style for bullet that's
solid
style queen trade you know stay up on
the clock
lars is basically sort of flailing going
for
speculative sacrifices and the thing
with
that style is that when it works i mean
you're kind of sailing you're feeling
great but when it doesn't work
you often experience a very good
defender and i think he met one today in
roberto molina
a very good defender is able to
frustrate that style
in a way that is so so annoying
and earlier in the match i think that
lars was playing well and caught roberto
in a style he wasn't quite comfortable
with i mean i see a knight in f5
and a reminder that earlier game on lars
was black and roberto sacrificed the
pawn but lars played really well
to save his king and then win uh the
game
and here it looks like you know the last
flails as you said
for lars at the time is about to end
right trying to
make things a bit spicy go after the g7
pawn hope that you can get
one for the road a victory last one
and i guess bishop g7 queen g4
it backfires you get mated first
yeah there's not a good way to to do
this
but knight's going to come back to g6
and that's going to be an extra
d-pawn yeah f6
yeah you can blockade the d-pawn but
you're still down
upon the knight comes back to g6 you
might just sack it
you think so i think there's a very real
chance
yeah it just doesn't amount to much at
least in terms of attack the match is
over yeah you might as well logic
so well done by roberto very impressive
and he's
farmed how many rating points at this
point like 40 rating points
from lars
and honestly and the resignation happens
the match is over
just just you know yeah yeah it didn't
make a difference
he just wants out yeah he's wonderful he
wants out so
what i was going to say is i'm not sure
it matters who
roberto faces i think he's the favorite
just based on what we saw today
in his previous matches yeah he's he's
basically made a case for himself
in bullet like uh not many others have
and he's made a case based on
consistency
2 800 level bullet but a consistent
style
not necessarily the most tactical you
know he goes toe-to-toe
in tactics when he needs to but he
doesn't initiate those tactical
sequences
um uh i think he's got a very solid
style and
that means that he's rarely going to
have matches where
he has blowouts so today
is really an exception to that he just
played amazing and bullet
lars didn't have the the attacks the
sacrifices
and you know his intuition didn't go his
way today
but in general i think uh he brought up
a great point roberto is looking
dangerous and you know greg shahadi and
levy rosman watching this match and
going oh man
i'm not even sure i want to win if i
have to play him
well we'll hear from the players in just
a few moments we'll get their thoughts
in a post-match interview
stay tuned everybody lars and roberto
will be joining us very shortly
[Music]
and we are back joined by the players
from today's match that is roberto
molina
and law's oscar hogg welcome guys uh
i go over you to to start there roberto
the
the match was a very very close affair
today in the blitz portion both of them
actually and then
it was actually the bullet section where
everything
everything changed and the final score
didn't feel like it reflected the match
um how did you feel about the match
overall because it looked like it was
very close to us
going into the bullet yeah uh
i i think some games i was
with a good position and i i blended
something but
the same way to
hosh and
i think if he
in these games i i was more for example
playing it accurate i think it
uh maybe the score
in blitz will will be some different
difference but ah it's it's
it's not my blitz now we can win
uh we can be winning but after a blunder
you can lost
i i i dropped some pieces i don't
remember
there
i definitely agree and lars on your end
you were facing an early deficit but
then you evened up the match it was
even for a long while and then towards
the end of the three minute portion
roberto started winning some games
including a checkmate in one on g2
would you say that's where the match got
away from you even before the bullet or
was something going wrong in the bullet
uh yeah like the last two of the
blitz games went like poorly when i
blundered mate in one
one unlike even either the game before
that or after i played very poorly
so when i went into the bullet and i
lost i just knew that
i didn't have a chance um so i started
like in the both games i just gave away
all pieces to try to end the game fast
but it's
it just ended in me losing every game so
i didn't stand chance in the bullet but
i think maybe i could have if
i played a bit better in the blitz games
because then i wouldn't have been so
aggressive in the blues games
yeah it makes sense to to go aggressive
when you need those points
at the end speaking of aggression you
know to highlight some of the good
moments you actually had a really nice
attacking game
in in the blitz portion where you had
his king all the way out on h5
g5 running around and there was a a nice
checkmate that looked like you were
going to deliver if uh
if he didn't flag but that i believe
that was against his
power khan did you do any preparation
against the the karo khan because that's
that's one of his uh main openings i
believe
yeah i i mainly prepared that's black
not that much as white so i just thought
that i would go for the um
i played like a year in the advanced
version like a knight c3 g4 line which i
had
like i knew pretty well but when you
played f6 i didn't know what to do so
that was the end line and like
kind of prepared in the car calm yeah
and roberto on your end we were very
impressed when you had some difficult
positions you were able to
trade queens but do so very
resourcefully and tactically
what can you say about your defense
today because that was just
as impressive as some of your more
tactical aggressive games
my style game is is always like this
changing queens going to 80 games isn't
looking for for some
technical position complication
complications uh positions
with very high complications i don't
like so much
and i prefer to avoid this but
it's for example some gaming with kingy
e7 i think i will
lost that game but in the
beginning of the match he said i don't
like this position
but but sometimes we need to play you
know
but i prefer change queens and play in
games and
understandable um and lars i wanted to
ask you about a position that it looked
like
you guys were both repeating from white
and black it seemed like this isolated
pawn position
um you were constantly getting it with
white and black is that because
uh you thought you had good chances here
or you know you you were you were happy
getting that position every time uh yeah
i was i i was happy with that position
both with black and white so i just
kept going for it but uh
i think i still scored pretty badly in
those positions like
when i had the black pieces like i kept
wandering on my six and in the car con
games with
white i uh
like the attack never worked so it
didn't turn out well
i was happy with the openings in almost
all the games
yeah you know it was a fantastic match
and uh roberto would be remiss not to
ask you
well you'll face the winner of levy
rosman gotham chess and greg shahadi
do you have a preferred opponent between
those two
no no i think both players are
very great and i just will watch in the
games and
maybe start some preparation i don't
know
but i will just watch the games justice
yep i think that's the best preparation
you can do and
if either of those guys were were
watching this match i'm sure they're
they're going to be uh well aware of of
who they're
they're going to be facing in the in the
final um well
guys i won't take more of your time but
uh lars
thank you for uh the interview and and
the match you made it very far in the
competition so
i hope you you definitely take solace in
that because we were always entertained
uh watching your matches and uh and also
to you roberto congrats
on the match win so gentlemen i'll let
you go but thanks for for participating
thank you thanks for reporting
thank you and congratulations once again
to roberto molina as you see in the
bracket in front of you
he is the first person to make his way
to the final he looked
dominant in the later stages of this
match
at the end of the three minute at the
bullet section of course i think he won
every single game and amman he faces the
winner
of greg shahadi and levi rosman now he
did not say who we'd prefer to play he's
a very nice guy
i honestly don't like asking that
question because it feels
like you're leading them to some answer
i just have to ask the question
he you know he didn't answer he's very
professional he said i'm gonna play who
i have to play and i'll prepare and all
that good stuff
but what do you think based on the
styles we saw uh sorry
the games we just saw from roberto whose
style
is roberto's play better matched up
against
um well it's kind of interesting because
if he plays against greg
i feel like those games are going to be
very very technical that's sort of how
i i feel like greg likes to play so um
not that that matchup is any more likely
than the rosman one but if
uh roberto likes those kind of queenless
middle games into end games technical
positions i feel like he can get a lot
of those
against greg so it'll be basically who's
better at that style
i feel like in that match whereas levy i
mean you're going to get fireworks no
matter what you're going to get time
trouble
there's always going to be other factors
at play in a levee rosman match and
that's why his matches are so exciting
so i think for different reasons
both of those matchups could be very
exciting i agree completely
and for roberto what is showing today
in the semi-final he should be really
proud of himself because
that was a stressful match we saw him
earlier he was hitting his own head
he was almost pulling his hair out it
seemed like he was the nervous one
and yet when it came down to the
quickest time control he was the one
that seemed very composed in the bullet
finding
good move after good move finding the
tactics when they became available
making sure his king was safe
when it needed to be protected so i have
to say that was an extremely
professional performance
by roberto molina in today's match yeah
i mean you you summed it up
lars is an incredible player and
the final score made it look like that
might not be the case
but of course it is the case i mean you
don't make it to the semi-finals for no
reason
lars has been so dominant especially in
the bullet portion so for that to
flip around today just speaks to uh you
know lars was saying
i was trying all these it's just attacks
they weren't working but
that's full credit to the defense that
roberto put on today so super impressed
by his resourcefulness
defense able to trade the queens as you
highlighted there's just so many things
that roberto did well
that i really feel like whether you know
he did preparation or not
he seemed well prepared for sure and
they
mantra is defense wins championships and
roberto he's the first to say i want to
trade queens i don't want the
complications
i prefer to have positions without all
the tactical sequences where i have to
be worried about missing one little
thing that just loses the game
so roberto style he's made it well known
we'll see who we face off
against the final but aman i gotta say
it was another great day commentating
with you i had a blast this match was
excellent full of ups and downs
there were mates in one hung on the
board there was time pressure galore
and yet everyone was happy we still have
nearly 10 000 people watching so i just
got to say thank you again partner it's
been a
fun ride and we still have another
semi-final and a final left
yeah let's you know remind the people
it's been uh awesome today but
there's been so much chess happening
that i feel like people need a
reminder now and again about this
tournament because we're
getting into the semi-final match with
levy as well as the
uh eventual final match between you know
whoever
wins that match and roberto molina and
this tournament has
been so exciting to cast that i think
with all the hype with pogchamps
we just got to remind people that hey
this tournament is not done yet and it's
only going to get more exciting from
here
filled with great chess content creators
great personalities and fantastic
players i think people often
forget about that and i know peter
svidler is a great example where people
like
oh he's an amazing chess commentator and
every now and then i have to remind
people
he's also an amazing amazing player who
has really
just a great impact on our game so i
have to
give a shout out to all the players in
this field there are only three left
roberto in the final
he'll await the winner of greg versus
levy but you're right this has been
fantastic
we are in for a treat we've already had
a great time there's more to come so
everybody
enjoy the rest of your days enjoy chess
and do not forget
on march 8th we will have levy vs greg
we'll see you there
[Music]
you